tu es de cette combinaison de couleurs
qui n'est pas évalués de la même manière
à la fois légale nous avions déjà
commencé à utiliser le protocole avec
les boutiques préoccupe bien avant que
le match ne commence son essai par
sénégal la chloroquine de maillage
donald est utilisé en ali décennies et
des décennies ça pourrait faire sourire
les c'est la galère que jean denys
choulet non il n'y a pas de signes qui
m'est rendu
voilà ce que j'ai trouvé
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue sur arte france
pour deux heures d'émission nous
décrypterons comme chaque soir du lundi
au jeudi l'essentiel de l'information
avec nos invités toujours tenus à bonne
distance et nos reporters sur le terrain
voici les titres de l'actualité de ce
jeudi 25 juin
pas de police violente pas de police
raciste selon la sémantique de
christophe castaner le ministre de
l'intérieur auditionné cet après midi
par les sénateurs alors que la militante
contre les violences policières à saint
traoré s'apprête à recevoir un prix
dimanche aux états unis
combien l'état at il mis sur la table
pour sortir la france de la crise du coc
vide 19 500 milliards d'euros selon
emmanuel macron qu'elle s'ajoute un plan
européen à venir de 750 milliards
mais au-delà de ces annonces
spectaculaires qu'elles sont
véritablement les dépenses engagées sont
elles à la hauteur de ces chiffres qui
marquent les esprits
jacques sapir tentera d'y répondre dans
son édito échos conques oculaire c'est
la nouvelle revue lancé par le
philosophe michel onfray
son objectif réunir les souverainistes
de gauche comme de droite dans les
colonnes d'un magazine
dont le premier numéro est sorti cette
semaine un média qui a pour ambition de
servir de socle programmatique pour un
candidat en 2022
michel onfray sera notre invité à 20h30
[Musique]
christophe castaner face aux sénateurs
cet après midi le ministre de
l'intérieur vient d'être auditionnés par
la mission d'information du palais du
luxembourg sur les méthodes d'action et
d'intervention des forces de l'ordre
en cause notamment les violences
policières et la technique controversée
dite de l'étranglement
on retrouve tout de suite lille a fait
rose ou en direct du sénat bonsoir li la
pa elle les accusations donc de
violences policières d'un côté on le
sait la colère des forces de l'ordre de
l'autre que faut-il retenir de cette
audition
alors cette année ce qui pouvait
retrouver il faut retenir pardon avant
tout c'est que le ministre de
l'intérieur s'est livré à un véritable
numéro d'équilibriste ici devant la
commission sénatoriale il a tenté par
tous les moyens d'apporter des réponses
aux problèmes des violences policières
tout en essayant de ménager les
syndicats alors dès le début de son
audition il a tenu à rappeler que le
gouvernement avait apporté une priorité
aux questions de sécurité il a tenu à
rappeler que depuis à 2017
cette priorité à la sécurité s'était
traduite par une hausse du budget allant
jusqu'à plus d'un 1 milliard d'euros
alors ils étaient très attendus sur
cette question christophe castaner qui a
tenu si certains pouvaient en douter a
rappelé qu'il était sans évident sans
problème est définitivement du côté des
forces de l'ordre je propose à l'écouté
nous devons le défendre sans cesse face
aux amalgames et aux accusations qu'ils
subissent les défendre face aux insultes
face aux coûts les défendre face à cette
accusation siens juste de racisme ou de
violence structurelle organisée je les
10000 fois je le dis une fois de plus il
n'y a pas de police violente
il n'y a pas de police racistes avec
laurent nunez
nous nous y employons depuis 20 mois et
nous ne cesserons de le faire et de le
dire nous avons confiance dans nos
forces de l'ordre ne cesserons jamais de
les soutenir leur accorder les moyens
dont ils ont besoin pour accomplir leur
devoir et je vous le dis nous sommes
fiers de nos policiers fiers de nos
gendarmes comme eux mêmes doivent être
fiers du métier qu'ils font au service
des français au service de la république
policiers et gendarmes sont les forces
de l'ordre au fond ils sont les forces
de la république que nous ne devons pas
l'oublier alors sur les questions des
méthodes d'interpellation qui sont a
très fortement contesté ces dernières
semaines notamment est la méthode dite
de la clé d'étranglement celle
d'ailleurs qui est mise en cause dans la
mort de cédric sauviac est décédé en
janvier dernier christophe castaner a
annoncé que cette méthode ne serait plus
enseigner
les écoles de police l'a d'ailleurs
évoqué des réflexions en cours pour
trouver d'autres méthodes d'intervention
jeu repose et l'écouté j'ai demandé à ce
que soit lancé un groupe de travail
conjoint entre la police et la
gendarmerie pour passer en revue les
techniques d'interpellation
à l'issue de ces travaux et estimant la
méthode comme dangereuse le directeur
général de la police nationale m'a
proposé de surseoir à l'enseignement de
l'étranglement
d'ailleurs elle n'est plus enseignée
depuis le début des années 2000 dans la
gendarmerie nationale ni dans
l'administration pénitentiaire et donc
en conséquence avec laurent nunez nous
avons décidé de mettre fin à son
enseignement
nous avons également et il n'y a pas eu
d'évolution ni de rétropédalage demander
un nouveau groupe de travail de faire
des propositions très vite d'ici le 1er
septembre pour trouver des alternatives
à cette méthode
je suis convaincu aussi que nous devons
faire monter en puissance la formation
continue des policiers et gendarmes sur
la voie publique et c'est pourquoi j'ai
décidé que les policiers et gendarmes
devraient désormais suivre un nombre
d'heures annuel minimal de formation aux
techniques d'intervention sans quoi il
ne pourrait plus exercer sur la voie
publique
c'est un ministre très fragilisée qui
s'est présenté aujourd'hui devant cette
commission sénatoriale un ministre qui
est très critiquée par ses troupes mais
qui aussi fragilisé politiquement
puisque il se murmure qu'il pourrait
perdre son poste au ministère de
l'intérieur au moment du remaniement qui
devrait se tenir après elle
élection aux municipales alors
christophe castaner qui était la
première personnalité à être auditionné
par cette commission qui a été mise en
place le 16 juin dernier devraient
suivre donc des représentants syndicaux
qui devraient venir ici se présenter
devant laisser le sénat jusqu'à la fin
du mois de juillet merci dit la femme au
zoo en direct du sénat et pour en parler
alexandre langlois le secrétaire général
du syndicat vigie police christophe
castaner a simplement dressé son bilan
pour lui peu reluisant écouter et dans
le mensonge le mensonge surtout ce qu'il
a annoncé
il a fait un bilan de glorifier le bilan
de son mandat alors que finalement il ya
rien à glorifier il ajuste truqués des
chiffres je donne un exemple il a
commencé par ça en disant qu'ils
auraient dix mille policiers de plus sur
le quinquennat alors que les deux
premières années déjà il ya 500 postes
qui n'ont pas été pourvus faute d'avoir
un niveau de recrutement assez haut par
rapport aux gens qui veulent passer le
concours et après ça continue il dit
qu'il va augmenter le budget alors que
le budget 2020 est à la baisse
il dit que le budget formation balte à
la hausse alors qu'il est déjà la baisse
cette année il est encore à la baisse
des prochaines donc on a en face devant
un mauvais joueur de poker dont le mieux
c'est qu'il s'en aille il a bien parlé
du suicide de nos collègues devant la
commission sénatoriale pour essayer de
faire pleurer dans les chaumières mais
il n'a rien fait pour apporter des
solutions à cela il a juste continuer de
compter les morts c'est quand même
catastrophique quand on est ministre de
l'intérieur il a d'ailleurs bien reconnu
que c'était un problème structurel de la
police nationale donc en fait faut faire
quelque chose qui installèrent l'a
également dit grâce à lui on a voté un
nouveau cycle de travail qui permet
d'avoir un week-end sur deux à mercredi
sur deux effectivement ça a été voté par
contre ce n'est pas appliquée dans les
faits donc on fait dans la poudre de
perlin papa ce qui fait que nos
collègues continuent d'avoir un week-end
sur 6 1 mercredi sur six il s'est vanté
d'avoir payé des heures supplémentaires
mais moins chers que leur normale ce qui
est déjà une honte on est soit payé
moins cher que d'autres normales il les
a budgété pour l'année prochaine plutôt
que de budgéter des heures
supplémentaires ce qui veut dire qu'on
sait qu'il va avoir besoin de renforts
renforçant des policiers mais tire ne
monte sur le terrain et arrêtons de
mettre de diriger la police n'importe
comment comme c'est le cas à l'heure
actuelle et pour en parler nous sommes
avec jean-pierre colombien est ce porte
parole de l'association de police union
des policiers
non indépendant bonsoir jean pierre
colombiès merci d'être avec nous alors
votre collègue de vigie vous l'avez
entendu parle carrément de mensonges
vous vous l'avez trouvé comment
l'audition de christophe bacca sa mère
globalement est globalement il a fait la
démonstration que lorsqu'on écrit un
discours on est toujours meilleur que
lorsqu'on se lance dans une
improvisation aléatoire et à risque ça
c'est un fait
ensuite je oui effectivement je voudrais
pas rentrer dans une sorte de machine
castaner de castetner bachy pour autant
on peut pas on ne peut pas nier que on
se demande quelle police il parle
lorsqu'on entend parler de psq kiki qui
est destiné à retourner vers les
quartiers qui est en fait une sorte de
copier-coller avec une nouvelle
adaptation une nouvelle dénomination de
ce que fut la police de proximité
on sait bien que sur le terrain ça ne
marche pas ça ne fonctionne pas tout
simplement parce que ça n'existe pas et
la réalité dijonnaise nous rappelle à
quel point le chemin est encore très
long à parcourir pour qu'une présence
policière crédible et légitime puisse
retourner dans les quartiers donc on a
eu droit effectivement des déclarations
d'intention des déclarations d'amour de
c'est effectivement de quelque chose qui
a été écrit et réfléchi en amont c'est
évident et j'ai envie de dire
heureusement pour autant bon il faudrait
des heures pour revenir sur tous les
points qui a évoqué lui dise de
l'intérieur mais à l'évidence ne compte
n'y est pas une taupe assiette
tout simplement parce que ça part comme
il le dit et là pour le coup il faut de
rendre cette justice sa part de très
loin des gouvernements qui ont précédé
celui ci n'ont pas pris en compte le
malaise et les difficultés profondes qui
règne au sein de cette institution
gouvernements précédents d'ailleurs je
vais peut-être a dit que quelqu'un lui
rappelle un certain emmanuel macron
faisait partie je rappelle qu'il était
quand même secrétaire générale sous la
présidence hollande est également
ministre du budget et comme l'a rappelé
monsieur questionnaire c'est tout part
souvent justement des arbitrages qui
sont effectués à bercy donc rendons à
césar ce qui est à césar et si
aujourd'hui on ne peut constater que tu
dirais globalement des échecs multiples
à tous les niveaux au niveau du maintien
de l'ordre au niveau de l'implantation
dans les secteurs au niveau des
méthodologies et bien c'est un petit peu
parce que des hommes au pouvoir
aujourd'hui n'ont pas tiré les
conséquences il de leçons du pouvoir
passer donc conseil il y avait un point
évidemment très attendu à cette fameuse
clé d'étranglement d'étranglement selon
un ministre de l'intérieur est bien
cette technique ne sera plus enseignée
elle sera encore utilisé mais plus
enseigner une réaction oui oui parce que
je vous savez ce débat est très
compliqué parce qu'on parle d'événements
qui ont provoqué la mort d'un individu
la mort de personne dom et c'est
toujours compliqué lorsqu'il ya une
forte charge émotionnelle de revenir sur
un débat est sur une technicité comme
cela bon maintenant soyons sérieux deux
secondes deux secondes
il y a dans ce pays des dizaines de
milliers de contrôle et d'interpellation
dans ce pays
combien sont-elles le dé générer de
façon aussi gravissimes très peu et
heureusement d'ailleurs
et c'est très bien maintenant je vais
vous dire une chose lorsque vous
intervenez dans un climat d'hypertension
de dangerosité immédiate que vous devez
faire face à un individu qui est
potentiellement extrêmement dangereuse
pour lui même comme pour autrui je vous
mets au défi de mettre en pratique
quelques techniques d'interpellation que
ce soit qui nous soit sans danger
c'est impossible tout simplement
impossible alors aujourd'hui on fait le
procès d'une technique on va les
substituer une autre et je peux vous
assurer que peut-être dans 5 ans 10 ans
ou l'année prochaine une nouvelle
polémique naîtra du fait de cette
nouvelle technique parce que tout
simplement il n'y a pas de technique
parfaite
chaque cas est particulier et lorsque
vous êtes face à une hyper violence face
à des individus qui sont de véritables
bêtes sauvages dans certains cas vous
n'avez pas d'autre choix que d'utiliser
tous les moyens à votre disposition pour
le maîtriser
donc c'est un débat qui malheureux qui
est triste parce que ça part comme je
voulais dit du décès d'un individu ça
c'est pas normal on est bien d'accord
mais nous prenons bien garde ben non
vraiment bien garde à ne pas jeter le
bébé avec l'eau du bain
parce que là pour le coup c'est tout
l'équilibré de ce qui fait le vivre
ensemble que nous mettons en péril jeter
l'opprobre sur l'institution police en
règle générale ou sur la gendarmerie je
rappelle quand même que adama traoré est
mort dans une gendarmerie et non pas
dans un commissariat
c'est prendre le risque est avéré que
demain nous soyons dans une société où
la police et la justice seront tétanisé
pour exercer leurs missions et ou de les
conflits ultra commune
notaire et communautarisme vont exploser
on l'a bien vu à dijon mais dijon dé
dijon vous savez il y en a partout en
france
et si on n'y prend pas garde si vraiment
basta garde si vraiment renonce à ce que
le pouvoir régalien existe vraiment au
plus profond des quartiers mais bien ces
exemples surmultipliée se démultiplier
je peux vous assurer qu'à un moment
donné ou à un autre il y aura des morts
il ya eu une annonce un sel en
concernant les caméras piétons
accélération en clair du déploiement de
ses nouvelles générations de caméras et
piétons c'est l'une des solutions info
vous c'est une des solutions dès lors
qu'elles sont exploitables et dès lors
qu'elles sont utilisées de façon honnête
et pragmatique ce que je veux dire par
là c'est que il ne faut pas qu'elle soit
perçue comme un ultra contrôle ou un
contrôle de plus de l'action policière
qui a en elle même est déjà très
contrôlé mais il faut aussi qu'elle soit
en capacité d'être utilisés contre les
personnes qui sont contrôlés car dans
certains cas dans de très nombreux cas
dans de trop nombreux cas les policiers
sont confrontés à des individus qui
n'hésite pas qui n'hésite jamais à les
insulter
alan manquer de respect à les provoquer
justement pour parfois en arriver à des
situations explosives et d'ultra
violence donc et ça je le regrette aussi
le ministre n'a pas eu un mot sur la
cohérence judiciaire dans ce pays qui
manquent gravement de sérieux on a
l'impression qu'ils à véritable
amateurisme dans dans la vision de que
par rapport à la cohérence judiciaire et
ça c'est dommage nous assurer qu'il
faudrait des heures pour remettre tout
ça à plat pour en discuter de manière je
dirais constructive mais on ne peut pas
traiter un problème sans remédier à un
autre c'est vrai véritablement un
enchevêtrement de problématiques
complexes face au calme serein face à
quoi nous sommes confrontés
il faudrait vraiment prendre le temps
que des gens sérieux et non pas des
amateurs et non pas des gens qui ne
raisonnent que par moss nos gants que
par des effets d'annoncé s'assoient
autour d'une table et travaille vraiment
vraiment sur des sujets concrets
merci beaucoup jean pierre à colombiès
de nous avoir accordé cette interview en
direct sur rt france cette question à
présent au chapitre économique combien
l'état at il vraiment mis sur la table
pour sortir la france de la crise ducobu
19 dans cette dans sa dernière
allocution et manuellement
on parlait de 500 milliards d'euros et
d'un plan européen à venir de 750
milliards
mais au-delà de ces annonces
spectaculaires quelles sont les dépenses
réellement engagées sont elles à la
hauteur de ces chiffres qui marquent les
esprits
on voit cela tout de suite avec
l'économiste jacques sapir en duplex
avec nous bonsoir jacquet merci d'être
avec nous alors
bonsoir vous ne semblez pas croire le
président de la république quand il
annonce que 500 milliards ont été
engagés pour la relance pour quelle
raison ce scepticisme alors il ne s'agit
pas d'accuser ici emmanuel macron
d'avoir voulu propager des défectueuses
mais il est très clair qu'il a au
minimum confondues les torchons et les
serviettes et c'est encore plus vrai si
on regarde ce qu'il dit non seulement
sur les actions du gouvernement français
mais aussi sur les actions de la
commission européenne donc je vous
propose de voir ça un petit peu on
détaille alors jacques commençant
justement par les mesures de soutien que
voulez vous dire avec mélanger les
torchons et les serviettes d'écouté
c'est très simple stéphanie vous prenez
les mesures qui ont été annoncées les
mesures de soutien qui ont été annoncées
à différentes activités ou des grands
secteurs de l'économie
eh bien vous voyez que dans la le projet
de loi de finances rectificative qui a
été déposée le 10 juin dernier
il ya absolument nous aucune mention qui
est fait d'un chiffre de 500 milliards
les chiffres que l'on trouve et qui sont
pas négligeables par ailleurs avoisine à
peu de choses près à 43 milliards
alors oui ce n'est pas négligeable mais
ces 43 milliards c'est pas 500 milliards
et qui plus est c'est très inférieur aux
chiffres identiques proposée par
l'allemagne parce que l'allemagne elle
se propose de mettre 130 milliards sur
la table pour une économie qui a été en
fait moins touchés par la crise du
coronavirus que l'économie française
alors jacques le soutien justement
l'économie ne se limite pas à ces
mesures
oui tout à fait il faut savoir que dans
le soutien il ya d'abord le coût du
chômage partiel qui est
très largement payés par l'état il y a
le soutien aux pme et il y as enfin le
soutien aux collectivités locales
là encore on arrive à peu de choses près
à 43 milliards c'est quelque chose qui
est important sauf que il faut savoir
qu'une partie de cet argent a déjà été
dépensée par exemple pour le chômage
partiel et que donc ce n'est pas de
l'argent que l'on peut assimiler à un
plan de relance alors à quoi vous avez
aussi parlé du manque à gagner pour
l'état engendrée par la crise économique
à combien sont ils
oui effectivement c'est fanny il ya un
véritable problème de manque à gagner
alors on le voit ce manque à gagner il
va toucher différents impôts évidemment
beaucoup touché l'impôt sur les sociétés
et on aboutit nll à un manque à gagner 2
66 milliards auxquels il faut ajouter et
ça ne figure pas dans le tableau il faut
ajouter effectivement 4 milliards qui
correspondent à différentes exemption
d'impôt voire des pertes qui touchent
des recettes non fiscales de l'état
nous arrivons à 70 milliards alors oui
c'est important mais cet argent
ce n'est pas de l'argent frais pour les
entreprises donc c'est 70 milliards là
encore il ne faut pas les compter dans
des mesures de soutien pour l'activité
économique
alors jacques as combien maintenant
sellem le coût pour le budget de la
crise ducobu de 19 et de ses
conséquences économiques
alors pour l'instant d'après toujours le
projet de loi de finances rectificative
le coût total ces 157 milliards même
dire 160 milliards avec la dérive qu'il
y aura sur le financement du chômage
partiel
on est donc très loin des 500 milliards
et qui ont été annoncées ces 160
milliards ça correspond à 6 5% du pib
pour 2010 9 par rapport au pib estimée
de 2020 ça correspondrait à 7,2 pour
cent
je rappelle qu emmanuel macron a parlé
d'un engagement de soutien de l'ordre de
20% du pib
trenet de manière tout à fait évidente
on n'y est pas draka comment emmanuel
rendons qu'arrive-t-il à cette fameuse
somme de 500 milliards d'euros
et bien parce qu'ils ajoutent aux
dépenses que va faire l'état ou au cou
qui sera supporté par le budget des
promesses de prêts et qu'ils sont faits
aux entreprises alors évidemment les
prêts ils doivent être remboursés c'est
pour ça qu'on ne peut pas les compter
de la même manière dans le solde
budgétaire et donc il faut rappeler que
sur ces prêts il a parlé grosso modo de
300 milliards alors effectivement 300
milliards de 160 milliards on s'approche
des 500 milliards sauf que là encore si
on regarde l'argent frais qui est
apportée que ce soit aux entreprises ou
par exemple aux collectivités locales ou
encore aux très petites entreprises
on est plutôt autour de 87 milliards et
87 milliards faut faire attention c'est
un sixième pratiquement des 500
milliards dont on le voit il y a une
très grosse différence alors dans 87
milliards et non 500 milles ou jacques
c'est quand même une différence
considérable vous signale également un
problème du même ordre avec les
promesses cette fois de l'union
européenne
oui tout à fait dans la manière dont
emmanuel macron à proa je dirais a
présenté ses promesses
il a confondu plusieurs choses tout
d'abord il ya effectivement la
proposition franco-allemande qui portait
sur 1500 milliards d'euros bien mais
c'est une proposition
après il y a la proposition faite par la
commission européenne à on est déjà un
peu plus sérieux 750 milliards d'euros
sauf que cette proposition n'est
toujours pas votée et on sait qu'il y à
un certain nombre de pays qui s'opposent
à ce type de mon temps en particulier ce
qu'on appelle les quatre frugaux 1
l'autriche les pays-bas la suède le
danemark
alors on est on est déjà en termes de
subventions pure on en est pour
l'instant plutôt de l'ordre de 310
milliards auxquels évidemment la
commission se propose d'inclure des
subventions qui ont déjà été d'une
certaine manière mise au budget pour 55
milliards
voilà on va pas chipoter on arrive
grosso modo à 365 milliards
et le reste ça devrait être là encore
des prêts faits aux entreprises ce qui
est important c'est que actuellement ce
sur quoi travaille la commission de
bruxelles
c'est plutôt de 560 à 615 milliards
suivant ce que l'on introduit là dedans
on n'est même pas au niveau des 750
milliards et donc on voit bien il y as
loin de la coupe aux lèvres
dans ce cas dit emmanuel macron à l'orge
action vous comprends bien pour vous un
emmanuel macron c'est un petit peu trop
avancé dans sa dernière allocution
oui mais si vous voulez stéphanie il
faut pas non plus être dupe il est
évident qu emmanuel macron fait de la
politique il est tout à fait évident
qu'il cherche à présenter de manière je
dirais intéressante pour ses futurs
électeurs
l'action du gouvernement quitte là
encore à ne pas correspondre tout à fait
avec la réalité
yves est aussi je dirais de son intérêt
et politiques de montrer que la
commission européenne et que l'union
européenne a réagi avec beaucoup de
promptitude et beaucoup d'efficacité a
fait créer ce qui n'est pas du tout le
cas et on le voit très bien au niveau
des sommes qui sont proposés mais d'un
autre côté il est peut-être aussi de
l'intérêt des français de connaître les
véritables chiffres les chiffres qui
sont indiqués en particulier dans les
deux dans les documents de la commission
européenne ou dans le projet de loi de
finances rectificative et merci jacques
voilà qui al'avantage d'être clair et
qui va nous faire évidemment réfléchir
merci à vous au chapitre judiciaire les
juges d'instruction relance enquête pour
prise illégale d'intérêt visant lexsi
colère le secrétaire général de l'elysée
conséquence des révélations de mediapart
qui reprochaient manuel macro de s'être
immiscé dans cette procédure qui touche
un de ses proches collaborateurs les
détails en images
[Musique]
oh
maquereau a écrit à la main une lettre
visant à absoudre alexis kohler des
chefs d'inculpation dont il fait l'objet
à mes questions pourtant très clair sur
cette affaire nicole belloubet fait
semblant de ne pas comprendre et répond
à côté pour mieux couvrir macro
nouvelles révélations accablantes de
mediapart sur le dangereux mélange des
genres entre pouvoir exécutif et
judiciaire sur une procédure concernant
le plus proche collaborateur du
président la séparation des pouvoirs est
elle trop ancien monde pour macron le
président de la république est intervenu
dans la sphère colère la question de
l'indépendance de la justice s'oppose
il y a quelque chose de pourri au
royaume de macro ni à lire mediapart
macro aurait écrit au pnf pour disculper
son collaborateur colère et pour couvrir
un mensonge d'état
il relève de la destitution alexis
kohler a été déchargé de toutes les
questions qui pouvaient concerner cette
entreprise avec laquelle il avait des
liens familiaux quand il était au
cabinet du ministre de l'économie
encore une fois il ya eu un an
d'investigations qui ont confirmé cela
je considère qu alexis colère est un
grand serviteur de l'état qu'il est
d'une probité total et ma confiance est
complète
il ne faut pas confondre la séparation
des pouvoirs qui est une règle absolue
mais là au fond si j'ai bien lu cet
article c'est une sorte d'attestation
d'employeur
cela se fait tous les jours en france
qu'un employeur atteste sur un
collaborateur ou sur un autre
[Musique]
dans quelques instants rester avec nous
serons avec michel onfray pour parler de
la sortie de la revue front populaire un
nom qui fait déjà grincer des dents
certains avec un premier numéro consacré
au souverainisme et qui entend dépasser
les clivages artificiels entre droite et
gauche de quoi peser peut-être dans le
débat politique et les échéances
présidentielles à venir
[Musique]
est-ce qu'on a une idée d'augmentation
ou pas des signes ici d'aujourd'hui en
france l'écho et les violences l'exister
avant le confinement et pendant ce
compliment c'est vrai qu'il ya sept ce
cadre lecture les dos des féminicides a
plus que je dis pas doublé mais bien
monté forcément on n'a pas encore tous
les chiffres officiels c'est très
difficile bourreau n'est jamais d âme et
loi a finalement c'est le confinement
dans le confinement
cela veut dire qu'il ya huit clos au
sein des foyers
et forcément donc les femmes victimes de
violences le nombre en 3e à 3 l'état a
mis sur la table une série de mesures
pour aider le secteur 18 milliards
d'euros pour le tourisme là pour
l'instant via les aides encore les aides
et donc que les choses vont se
compliquer à la rentrée bockel ça parle
beaucoup mais il faut il faut du concret
et les fonds de solidarité
2500 euros et ses terrasses et des
pacotilles tout ça c'est c'est mal fait
c'est mal préparée donc comment voulez
vous que les gens s'y retrouvent le plus
dur c'est à venir et c'est là où pour
l'armement contrôler ça va être
compliqué de faire revenir les gens pour
la bonne et simple raison qu'on a tous
perdu beaucoup de revenus
donc de toute façon on est on est dans
une impasse
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
certains disent que nous ne sommes pas
une chaîne française
d'autres affirment même que nous ne
sommes pas journalistes mais vous
[Musique]
savez-vous vraiment qui nous sommes
les valeurs que nous défendons la
liberté
la liberté d'expression et d'opinion
nous défendons l'égalité l'égalité des
chances pour tous
[Musique]
nous sommes une équipe
nous sommes cette diversité qui fait la
france
et nous en sommes fiers
[Musique]
et si vous veniez voir par vous même
20h30 soit il est bienvenu en direct sur
rt france le nouveau projet de michel
onfray réunir les souverainistes de
gauche comme de droite dans les colonnes
d'un magazine dont le premier numéro
vient de sortir front populaire c'est
son nom doit selon l'essayiste
philosophe servir de socle pour le
programme d'un candidat à la
présidentielle de 2000 22 avant de
recevoir michel onfray voici une
présentation en images
[Musique]
nous avons le plaisir d'accueillir
michel onfray philosophe essayiste
bonsoir michel onfray merci d'être avec
nous nous avoir accordé cet entretien en
direct sur arte france avant la question
qu'on a souvent dû forcément vous poser
pourquoi front populaire votre revue
n'est pas nécessairement une coalition
des partis de gauche
vous avez fait une présentation qui est
un peu le sidérant de on n'a jamais dit
qu'on était national national
souverainiste sais pas d'où vous sortez
cette expression spagnou ce sont nos
ennemis qui disent plutôt ça ensuite je
n'ai pas dit que nous souhaitions réunir
les souverainistes de droite et de
gauche points mais de droite de gauche
d'ailleurs et de nulle part c'est pas
exactement la même chose il ya la moitié
de notre proposition puisqu'elle ce qui
nous en veulent veulent absolument
imaginer que j'ai dit de gauche et de
droite pour dire c'est surtout de droite
et pas du tout de gauche c'est ce qu'on
peut lire absolument sûr toutes les
colonnes des médias aujourd'hui qui vous
ont on a fait une belle tribune en tout
cas qui re annoncé votre voilà cette
revue c'est vrai que c'est ce qu'on
pouvait lire absolument partout si tous
mobilisés que c'est faux comme ça on est
au moins c'est très clair si tout bon de
genre libération le monde
charlie hebdo france inter france
culture si tous les gens disent à peu
près la même chose d'ailleurs ils disent
toujours la même chose le premier qui a
menti donne le ton à tous les autres qui
vont mentir et qui vont continuer de
mentir
donc je vois des gens qui depuis plus
d'un mois sont en train de parler d'une
revue qui est en kiosque depuis 24
heures 48 heures donc bernard henri lévy
a estimé que j'étais au jacques doriot
jacques doriot est quand même quelqu'un
qui a porté l'uniforme nazi sur le front
russe qui était fasciste
julia un délire complet de la part de
tous ses journaux discussions finalement
propriété des deux de même famille de
milliardaires qui sont d'ailleurs
subventionnés par les impôts de l'état
voilà donc des gens qui nous ont dit que
cette revue était rempli de nationaux
souverainistes de fasciste et terrasses
a fait 48 heures qu'on peut la voir
et depuis 16h depuis deux jours de 16
heures il y a deux jours j'irai 500
points de vente se sont privés de la rue
parce que tout le monde se jette dessus
donc voilà des gens qui parlent d'un
film qui n'ont pas vu qui parle d'un vin
qui n'ont pas bu qui parle de livres qui
n'ont pas lui qui parle d'une revue
qu'ils n'ont pas encore eu entre
les mains tout ça ce sont bien les
méthodes de la presse qui effectivement
mans comme un seul homme et ça c'est un
peu ce qui les caractérise donc oui elle
dit des bêtises et comme le monde est le
premier à dire des bêtises libération
s'empresse de lendemains de dire la même
bêtise et le surlendemain je prends cinq
archers de même c'est donc plutôt la
preuve et c'est jean lin sont de
connivence ne disent pas la vérité alors
on s'excuse d'avoir repris ses bêtises
et on est absolument ravie de vous
accueillir sur un entretien longue durée
pour que vous puissiez rétablir votre
vérité parce que évidemment c'est
important je vais dire cette fiabilité
philippe bilger ne fait pas partie des
contributeurs non plus si vous voulez
qu'on reprenne les choses les unes après
les autres
philippe bilger le minime de beaucoup
philippe huguen mai et on l'a pas
approcher nous a pas approchés il ne
fait pas partie du comité d'action il
n'a pas donné de texte il ne fait pas
partie de l'équipe donc c'était parti
effectivement dit justement ces fausses
informations effectivement qu'on a
vraiment pu lire dans des presses quand
même sérieuses qui sont supposés
vérifier les informations un journal le
monde effectivement est supposé quand
même vérifier l'information comment vous
vous l'expliquer et un manque justement
de vérification des sources où il ya une
volonté peut-être de mal présenter votre
projet dois-je vraiment sérieusement que
le monde est un journal sérieux la
question oui en tout cas il est présenté
comme tel oui il est présenté par les
journaux comme un journal sérieux mais
comme lille se sont tous copains et
coquins
évidemment le monde parce qu'on l'a
journal de référence mais ça passe pour
un journal de référence pour les
journalistes qui eux mêmes sont entre
les mains de quelques milliardaires qui
en plus de sa demande de l'argent du
contribuable pour pouvoir faire une
propagande éhontée depuis une vingtaine
d'années donc ça fait bien longtemps que
je ne lis plus les journaux là ou alors
juste pour savoir quel est le ton d'un
propagande mais non le monde n'est pas
sérieux le monde dit n'importe quoi
les propos que vous avez repris en
pensant que le monde était un journal de
référence vous font dire effectivement
les bêtises que ces gens là disent nous
savons que nous n'avons jamais été des
nationaux souverainiste nous n'avons
jamais été si no sunshine par exemple
jamais sollicité philippe bilger que
j'aime beaucoup de lieux reniement mais
ce sont de fausses informations sont lus
que par les journalistes mais on va
tenter alors d'en savoir plus avec votre
parole à vous qui est la seule qui
compte puisque c'est votre revue vous
vous lancez alors sur le web et j'espère
qu'on ne va pas se tromper cette fois
votre revue se décrit comme un par
l'homme
en perpétuelle des idées où le peuple
pourra faire des propositions pour
rebâtir notre monde alors cela fait qu
évidemment à certaines revendications
populaires qu'on a beaucoup entendu ces
derniers temps notamment du côté d'eads
et gilet jaune pour vous le peuple n'est
clairement pas assez entendu quand le
système actuel n'est pas entendue mais
ensuite il est maltraité vous voyez
comment moi qui suis maltraitée j'ai les
moyens de répondre parce
qu'effectivement vous m'invitez mais
dire le peuple lui même n'est jamais
invités et puis pour cause quand on dit
de lui qu'il est un habit un imbécile
qui est un crétin qu'ils votent mal
qu'il faut l'éduquer
qu'il abatte -12 qu il vit en province
que ce sont des paysans des ploucs dp
corps des péquenots et aidera tous les
tous les jours du léger les jaunes s'en
sont pris plein la figure et quand par
exemple on a sollicité le peuple en 2005
en me disant que voulez vous de ce
traité européen il mettre un coup
d'accélérateur libéral le peuple dit non
merci nous ne souhaitons pas cette
europe là nous sommes européens mais une
volonté d'une europe libérale et bien en
2008 on dit au peuple vous vous êtes
trompé votre votre référendum on
l'envoie à la poubelle on va demander au
congrès c'est-à-dire l'assemblée
nationale et au sénat de voter contre
vous donc oui le peuple a bien compris
que l'on me faisait porter le chapeau
on a associé effectivement ligier les
jaunes à des casseurs alors que
finalement les casseurs c'était des
black blocs qui peut qu'il y enfiler le
gilet jaune il ya eu parfois quelques
provocations parce que castanet
ministère de l'intérieur ne sont pas
contre ce genre de pratiques mais non le
peuple n'est pas fou et maltraités
humiliés moquer depuis 1983
mitterrand est passé à droite et il a
persisté à dire qu'il était de gauche et
il a maltraité le peuple ça fait un
quart de siècle que cette europe
libérale dispose des pleins pouvoirs et
de la totalité de ces médias qui font
donc finalement sont des médias qui ce
qui endoctrinent donc eu à un moment
donné où le peuple il a essayé on a
compris
au bout de trente ans vous nous aviez
proposé des choses formidables la fin du
chômage de la misère la pauvreté la
disparition du racisme tout ça allait
être merveilleuse qui ont voté oui à
maastricht et demi au libéralisme et
puis on a eu le contraire augmentation
de l'antisémitisme la xénophobie de la
haine de la concentration des
informations c'est à dire de la
propagande entre les mains de quelques
milliardaires
et puis
insultes en lieu et place de débat s'est
terminée aujourd'hui de plus débattre on
sait tout de suite insultes et donc le
peuple je dirai au sens large du terme a
bien compris comment les manoeuvres à
fonctionner et ne s'occuperait et je ne
sont plus capables et maintenant d'en
supporter plus longtemps regardé ce
gilet jaune combien dieu ils ont perdu
combien de mains ils ont perdu combien
de 2,2 de gens parmi eux ont perdu la
santé le maquereau envoie la police
contre le peuple quand ils n'en voient
pas la police il en voit les résultats
du référendum à la combler est ce que
vous qualifiez votre revue dans tes
système où c'est un raccourci que vous
réfléter non notre anti système ne
marche
on est juste en train de dire que nous
ne croyons qu'à la république c'est à
dire que la démocratie c'est le pouvoir
du peuple par le peuple pour le peuple
c'est une évidence et une banalité et là
ce n'est plus le cas le pouvoir n'existe
plus par le peuple pour le peuple
il existe pour servir les intérêts du
libéralisme l'état français disparaît au
fur et à mesure l'autorité du chef de
l'état n'existait plus ça se voit
régulièrement et tout ce qui se passe
dans les banlieues toutes deux tout au
tout les gens qui ont pu dire nous on a
rien à faire par exemple du processus de
déconfinement on sort quand on veut on
fait ce qu'on veut on peut faire des
matches de football sur des prières on
va faire tout ce qu'on veut on en arrive
à cela et il ya effectivement un moment
donné on se dit cette cette république
là il n'existe plus nous nous voulons
nous sommes des républicains
nous voulons reprendre la déclaration
des droits de l'homme en dix ans mais il
y a un droit par exemple à la sûreté
dans la déclaration des droits de
l'homme et du citoyen de 1789 il n'y a
plus aujourd'hui de sûreté qui soit
assurée vous avez plusieurs centaines de
lieux dans la république française qui
ne sont plus des lieux républicain où la
loi de la république n'est plus ce n'est
plus active
donc nous nous souhaitons simplement
nous redonner les moyens intellectuels
de repenser le débat ce que dans la
présentation vous nous avez présenté
comme une revue quillan au prépare
l'arrivée de d'un candidat aux
prochaines présidentielles c'est pas le
cas du tout numéro départ nous avons
voulu faire une revue de réflexion pour
qu'on puisse dire qu'on était souverain
sans être forcément un nationaliste dont
quelqu'un de belliqueux et puis par la
suite on s'est aperçu qu'on avait un
afflux considérable de deux lecteurs
d'abonnés on a passé les trente mille
abonnés alors que la revue n'était même
pas encore en kiosque et que personne ne
l'avait vu et on s'est dit mais
on a des obligations on a des devoirs à
l'endroit de ces gens donc si on fait
remonter des propositions il faut que
ces propositions puissent être
praticable et qu'elles puissent
éventuellement être pratiquée donc après
ça prendra la forme que ça devra prendre
on est des empirique on n'est pas parti
en se disant on va faire émerger un
candidat pour les prochaines
présidentielles mais si la question se
pose on l'examinera et puis après tout
pourquoi pas mais les français n'ont pas
envie d'un second tour avec mâcon et
marine le pen
donc si intellectuellement peut
contribuer à l'équipement de ce genre de
dégâts du débat qui n'est pas un débat
eh bien on aura fait notre travail
justement ce candidat là on a compris
que c'était pas votre première en
mission avec cette revue contrairement
encore une fois ce qui est effectivement
présenté dans toutes les presses
l'ambition voilà un programme de socle
pour pour la présidentielle en tout cas
ce candidat idéal vous le verriez
comment pour la prochaine présidentielle
une autre aventure on et
autogestionnaire te dire qu'on pense
qu'il ya un génie du peuple et que s'il
faut régler les problèmes de la médecine
ils vont me demander à des médecins des
infirmières des d'un petit travail ou à
des hommes qui travaillent dans les
hôpitaux routes pour la pêcherie
française pour la paysannerie française
pour l'université l'éducation la
recherche et il vaut mieux aller
demander aux gens qui sont compétents
parce qu'ils ont la pratique et la
connaissance de notre discipline
ce que sont la proposition plutôt que de
demander à des énarques à des gens qui
ont ces sciences pour moi des gens qui
font de la politique un métier qui sont
dans la politique politicienne depuis
depuis des décennies de leur demander
leur avis ni notre modèle il savait dans
l'histoire c'était dans les années 70
slip c'est à dire des gens qui
fabriquait des montres et qui à un
moment donné ce sont guy eh bien nous on
va autant gérer notre notre aventure est
aujourd'hui avec internet avec le site
que mâcon a lancé le jour du 18 juin est
pas par hasard c'est notre appel à nous
et bien non on dit fait chaque donc des
cahiers de doléances faisons des états
généraux perpétuelle ce que macro
indiqué que j'aurais qu'il n'a
évidemment pas fait et puis remontant
quelque chose qui va ressembler à un
programme et puis après si ce programme
sert mal tel ou tel pour autant et si un
jour quelqu'un sort de la société civile
et qui peut porter lui-même ce projet ce
ne sera pas moi je les dis eh bien on
pourra pourrait parler conditionnel on
pourrait éventuellement l'aider mais a
priori notre revue n'est pas là pour
servir d'autres
plein qui que ce soit pour devenir un
chef de l'état on a bien compris vous
parlez de la république res publica la
chose publique ça veut dire que tout
finalement le système de la vème
république serait à revoir selon vous
parce qu'on vous le savez très bien il
donne énormément de pouvoir insolent
parce que ce n'est pas ton cela qu'il
faudrait revoir avant vous vous avez la
vème république est morte je vous le dis
dis pas ça devrait pas être un scoop et
l'aluminé mortes depuis qu'on l'a
détruite il reste à peu près à 1 tient
discuter la constitution de 58 donc
quand par exemple en 1992 avait
peut-être le traité de maastricht la
france renonce à sa souveraineté
moi je dirais c'est 100% de la
constitution qui n'existent plus donc on
fait semblant d'avoir une constitution
disant amis il faut absolument un
conseil constitutionnel qui va nous dire
est-ce qu'il ya constitutionnalité de
telle ou telle loi mais ça c'est pour
faire semblant c'est terminé un pays
dispose de sa souveraineté quand ils ne
disposent plus de ça c'est la
souveraineté ce n'est plus un pays donc
la france n'est plus souveraine
le nouvel album quoi nous sommes
souverainiste et la constitution ne sert
plus à rien c'est un cetain c'est un
chiffon de papier
donc je ne repose propose pas le retour
aller à la vème république en disant
heureux dans le texte de départ on peut
imaginer une sixième république qui
ferait sa place à ce que le général de
gaulle appelait sur la fin 202 de son
exercice politique par exemple la
régionalisation la participation ce sont
des façon particulière de faire de la
politique à nouveaux frais c'est-à-dire
pas en jacobins mais plutôt un girondin
en laissant une place importante aux
régions aux communes aux départements au
peuple lui même en disant mais
finalement le talent il n'est pas chez
les gens qui ont fait sciences po et
l'ena mais il est chez les gens qui
travaillent et qui ont des choses à dire
c'est ce qui s'appelle du populisme
quand on a envie d'insulter les gens vie
qui sont polis mais moi je veux bien
passer pour un populiste parce que
finalement l'alternative c'est populiste
ou populicide il ya ceux qui tuent les
peuples symboliquement métaphoriquement
et puis ceux qui estiment que le peuple
doit être l'épicentre de la politique je
vous le rappelle le gouvernement du
peuple par le peuple pour le top alors
un sondage qu'il a peut-être vous faire
sourire ou peut-être dans le fond vous
flatter en tout cas c'est pas nous qui
le sortent on sait le sondage ifop pour
valeurs actuelles à la question
seriez-vous prêt à voter pour michel
onfray à l'élection présidentielle de
2000 22
je vous laisse regarder c'est quand même
beaucoup 9%
alors ça vous inspire quoi ça ça veut
dire qu'il ya vraiment
voilà une force beaucoup aujourd'hui de
monde finalement partage le type d'idées
que vous êtes en train de nous présenter
c'est surtout surtout ridicule de
vouloir que je sois candidat alors j'ai
dit depuis cinq cents fois que je ne
veux pas être candidat donc j'y vois pas
pourquoi vous voulez absolument que je
sois candidat et qu'on commence à tester
en disant un corner comme des pains etc
j'étais mis en balance avec bigard que 2
96% je crois que les gens connaissaient
et qu'ils lui devaient être 13% alors
que dire ça te dit quelque chose
effectivement des idées que vous portez
voilà au delà de votre personne ça ça te
dit quelque chose sur la société
aujourd'hui et sur la rupture peut-être
avec un système traditionnel et un
système rpt effectivement des élites que
vous dénoncez parfois pas du tout c'est
a dit que c'est débile les sondages le
dirigeant n'a aucun par exemple qu'ils
étaient capables en 2002 de nous dire
que jean marie le pen serait trésor
second tour il a aucun sondage
et pourtant il ya eu beaucoup il ya
beaucoup d'argent ils sont dehors ils
s'en font de l'argent en ce moment là
vous allez voir ça va bientôt commencer
et ça commence déjà avec ce genre de
choses
il n'y a aucun par exemple de ces
sondeurs qui a été capable de dire que
gainey jospin ne seraient pas présents
deuxième tour des élections
présidentielles en 2002 donc le sondage
c'est n'importe quoi ce sont ces faits
pour permettre à des partis politiques
de donner de l'argent à leurs copains
pour fabriquer des des opinions des
mouvements d'opinion et on veut
absolument intégrer dans un mouvement
d'opinion mais je dis simplement je ne
veux pas je le dis dès le départ donc
pas pourquoi on continue à dire ah mais
si michel onfray était candidat skm
voiturier pour lui et il connaît pas
connu s'il était plus connue faisons des
aînés des les calculs si plus de gens le
connaissaient combien retrait etc
leur motion frais ça vous dit quoi de
faire 9% hypothétiquement mais avec des
données corrigées cite moi de vous
connaissez ça fait plutôt 15% alors vous
en dites quoi
j'en dis que j'ai dit que ça ne
m'intéressait pas et que je vois pas
l'intérêt je ne vois pas l'intérêt
façon de parler je ne vois pas l'intérêt
de faire ce genre de sondages sauf à ce
que emmanuel un conte et intérêts à
fabriquer des diversions et je le sais
assez malin pour pousser des gens et en
revenir d'autres on dire en me
téléphonait tous ses adversaires
téléphoner à zemmouri la téléphonie à
bigard et la téléphonie à finkielkraut
d'accord forme non pas du tout et je
fais soumis mais mon billet qui ne
m'appellera jamais sûr peut-être après
m'avoir entendu si on lui rapporte
mais parce que les lycées bien qui est
dangereux qui n'est pas dangereux il
sait bien qui est son adversaire qui ne
l'est pas il sait bien qui est flatté
qui ne l'est pas on finit toujours par
le savoir que ces coups de fil au mieux
ils sont tous très heureux il ya des
gens qui ont reçu des coups de fil dans
dix ans le président m'a appelé et bien
moi ça ne m'aurait pas d'être appelé par
ce monsieur qui je fait savoir que je
n'ai pas l'intention de 2,2 me parler
parce que ma soupe et sur le feu exigé
plus important à faire que de lui parler
effectivement vous le disiez vous même
en début de cette interview beaucoup de
critiques
voilà on en passe et des meilleurs vous
seriez devenu national il sera soumis ce
passéisme manipulateur vendu à l'ultra
droite
j'ai même lu fasciste bon on vous a
qualifé même de revues nazi avant même
sa publication
cette voie là cette violence pour les
propos ça veut dire quoi que vous faites
peur vous inquiéter oui il est pas dans
lequel il se trouve
c'est à dire si effectivement j'imagine
ma biographie mois elle témoigne pour
moi j'ai fait et l'université populaire
quand j'ai fait des universités
populaires du goût j'ai fait du
bénévolat pendant toute ma vie j'ai dans
la vie que j'habitais argentan dans une
sous préfecture des expositions de
peinture pendant pendant dix ans sans
jamais parler de ces choses là je me
suis fait mettre à la porte de france
culture par le pouvoir les jeunes les
journaux n'ont pas parlé non plus tu
dirais l'universté lobulaire qui
existait un camp a été interdite par le
maire de caen par les universitaires de
caen mais ça on n'a évidemment jamais
parler non plus et bien ce qu on
découvre que je suis nazi formidable
ainsi suivre que j'ai écrit et plus
d'une centaine de lits l'origine
beaucoup parlé et je demande à ce que
depuis 1989 date de mon apparition dans
le don dans le monde littéraire dans le
monde des idées on trouve une seule
phrase qui vont trouver que je défends
les chambres à gaz des étoiles juive les
déportations les camps de concentration
l'idée que j'aurais dit des juifs que
c'était une race inférieure et qu'il
faudrait restaurer la supériorité d'une
race aryenne ce genre de chaussée sans
un nazi alors si moi je suis un nazi
nazisme le nazisme c'est pas si grave
pourquoi at-on droit d'être
négationniste et révisionniste dans ces
cas là
c'est pas grave le nazisme si c'est
michel onfray les franchement vous
expliquer la violence de ces propos
contrevenaient aux frais or ils ont peur
ils détiennent les médias ils détiennent
le pouvoir économique ils détiennent le
pouvoir médiatique ils détiennent de
bouard universitaire pour le pouvoir
dans l'édition dans les revues partout
ils font la loi partout partout partout
et ils ne veulent pas que quelqu'un
arrive en disant mais nous on est libre
on n'appartient pas des banquiers on
appartient pas de milliardaires
n'appartient pas à des publicitaires on
appartient au lecteur ce sont les
lecteurs qui font notre notre existence
il a apprend bien mais ils ont beaucoup
d'argent parce que normal michel onfray
il aime beaucoup d'argent oui j'ai fait
j'ai fait à peu près une trentaine
d'années de bénévolat pour quelqu'un qui
aime beaucoup l'argent je vois et puis
qu'on dise parce que dans l'extrait ci a
effectivement un anonyme extrêmement
courageux qui dit que je ne suis
intéressé que par l'argent mais
j'aimerais bien que monsieur dees il est
intéressé par l'argent parce que voilà
lui fait des guides que des consciences
alors je peux vous donner des noms de
collègues qui font des différences à
15000 et 20000 euros ou des gens qui
partent huit jours en croisière sur un
bateau avec leurs femmes parfois avec
leurs maîtresses ou parfois avec leurs
enfants et qui sont payés 50 ou 60 mille
euros pour aller faire des reçus ces
diverses et multiples et qui parfois
utilise quelques-uns de mes travaux sans
les citer et qu'on le dise effectivement
qu'on dise jalons free ladilafé les
conférences payer vingt mille euros pour
des jeux parfois des pharmaciens des
notaires qu'on fasse savoir que j'ai été
le philosophe de service sur des
croisières
et puis à ce moment là les joueurs ont
le droit de dire que je suis un [ __ ]
et que l'argent m'intéresse je demande
juste des preuves je bien être et nazis
mais je vous dis il va falloir qu'on
m'explique où quand comment de quelle
manière avec quels textes qu'elle livre
quel engagement non voici manqué une
panique totale de tous ces gens qui
sortent du même terrier et les gens ne
sont pas dupes ils découvrent
effectivement qu'il y a un pouvoir qu'il
tient qui tient le peuple sous sa botte
et comme on le dit nous ils ont les uns
les autres dans l'équipe populaire et
avec mon ami stephen sinon bah
évidemment on fait peur à des gens qui
n'ont pas intérêt à ce qu'on dise que le
roi est nu
alors les contributeurs en tout cas qui
vous suivent y en a plein de divers
horizons jean pierre chevènement
philippe de villiers
l'ancien gilet jaune jacqueline moureaux
des personnalités de droite comme de
gauche continue en commun selon vous ils
ont en commun le souverainisme le
souverainisme l'art de dire quand
quand la voiture est prête à sortir de
la route parce qu'on voit bien qu'elle
est en train de sortir de la route etc
et prend la direction du fossé on
reprend le volant on reprend le volant
en disant eh bien on reprend la maîtrise
du véhicule qui est en train de se
précipiter au fossé c'est ça le
souverainisme c'est d'abord une méthode
ça veut pas dire après que l'on va
continuer en avançant et au mois
reculant ou en prenant à droite ou un
peu en apprenant à gauche c'est d'abord
reprenons les commandes
et puis après si on reprend les
commandes c'est pour faire une politique
et cette politique
je ne vais pas clé en main je dis
simplement que nous voulons la faire
remonter du peuple parce que je pense
que l'autogestion et la meilleure des
choses
arrêtez de de laisser les pleins
pouvoirs à une bureaucratie à une
administration à des politiciens
professionnels à des gens qui font de la
politique depuis depuis début d année je
pense à jean luc mélenchon qui n'a
jamais travaillé sa profession c'est
d'avoir fait de la politique on en a
assez des gens qui font de la politique
politicienne il faut retrouver l'esprit
citoyen de 2,2 des grecs par exemple ou
des romains et ce sont les citoyens qui
font de la politique ce ne sont pas des
gens qui en ont fait une profession
donc nous c'est ce qu'on souhaite c'est
ce qu'on souhaite effectivement il ya
plein de gens qui qui se partageant le
fromage de la politique politicienne se
disent il faut absolument discréditer ce
type l'insultent on le méprise on le
traitons le nazi et fasciste dont phil
refoulé julie droite ou des personnages
rustique entier de deux des personnages
intéressé par l'argent mise en croix il
qu'ils croient quoi ces gens là que l'on
nous fait une revue pour se mettre de
l'argent dans les poches mais moi si
vous voulez je peux vous parler des
notes de frais de par exemple maurice
szafran a estimé que j'étais que j'étais
je faisais partie de ces de ses
nationaux socialistes d'aujourd'hui
moi j'ai pas fais des notes de frais
tellement terrible dans la maison du
caviar que l'on n'aurait en mauvais
termes en référé support précédent donc
il ya un tas de gens qui ont
probablement des choses à se reprocher
et qui te disent bon sens dans cette
revue qui n'ont rien à se reprocher ils
ont des gens plutôt plutôt sincère qui
n'ont pas de casier judiciaire et bien
évidemment tous ces gens là se
déchaînent s'imposera plus normal
même est ce que je me trompe si je vous
dis qu on vous sent quand même peut-être
voilà touché peut-être blessé par toutes
ces critiques vous on vous entend votre
honnêteté votre sincérité
voilà vous sortez une revue pour
exprimer vos idées les idées de vos
contributeurs et c'est vrai que il ya
voir ces critiques très violentes et on
comprend que ça puisse plus quand vous
agacer à ce qu'aujourd'hui vous santé du
blessé tour même si louis pascal on se
dit mais ça fait vingt ans que ça dure
fait quinze ans que ça dure c'est pas la
première fois que j'ai fait un livre sur
freud il ya des années et plutôt de lire
ce livre sur faute il était déjà en
librairie qui avaient déjà une cabale
contre moi il y avait d'ailleurs une
pétition pour interdire la diffusion de
wancourt sur france culture au nom de la
liberté d'expression et est bien la
première campagne contre moi et qui a
été fait contre ce livre là a déjà dit à
cette époque là que j'étais antisémite
donc l'accusation d'antisémitisme et les
très très ancienne très ancienne donc la
première fois c'est blessant parce qu'on
se dit mais je suis pas antisémite gg
chain l'iran disant que freud était un
imposteur
en appuyant médire sur son oeuvre sur sa
correspondance sur ces affreux ici sur
ces affirmations mais c'est lui qui
dicte la psychanalyse est une imposture
et 17,1 blanchiment de [ __ ] peut pas
mieux dire
et bien que c'est une imposture et bien
tout la même presse celle d'aujourd'hui
là qui me vomi dessus
il est parti comme un seul homme à
l'époque en disant que j'étais
antisémite
alors oui à cette époque là ça m'a
blessé et puis après j'ai compris que
écoutez si si vraiment les gens estiment
que je suis un nazi
alors c'est qu'on est tombé vraiment
bien ben c'est que personne n'est dupe
c'est bernard henri lévy qui estime que
je suis jacques doriot aujourd'hui mais
enfin moi j'ai pas de sang sur les mains
je suis pas c'est pas moi qui a
déclenché les guerres en libye par
exemple qui suis responsable de l'état
dans lequel se trouve l'irak où d'autres
pays bombardé avec son assentiment ou
avec le avec le fait qu'il est désiré
que la france bombarde partout partout
partout partout en palestine en libye en
irak en afghanistan au mali voilà un
monsieur qui demande à ce qu'on tue des
populations civiles il
après 4 5 millions de musulmans depuis
une vingtaine d'années un peu partout
sur la planète à cause de l'impérialisme
occidental
bernard henri lévy qui soutient cette
logique a dit que je suis jacques doriot
ça veut dire que je suis un nazi et non
moi je n'ai pas de craintes d'ordre sur
mes deux oreilles
ça n'est pas parce que ce monsieur
m'insulte de bord autant j'estime que
sont insultés et crédible il ne fait pas
partie des gens pour lesquels j'ai
quelques estime que ce soit il ya
d'autres personnes dans la vie qui
pourrait me faire de la peine en pensant
d'un dd des choses désagréables sur moi
alors il est loin d'en faire partie et
je vous assure que les gens de
libération du monde n'en font pas partie
non plus ça n'est pas mon monde
il ya des gens que j'estime parce qu'ils
sont honorables tous ces gens là sont
déshonorés déshonorant pas honorable du
tout donc je tiens pour une quantité
négligeable leurs insultes je vous
assure que ça empêche pas de dormir ça
fait plutôt sourire et ça me donne
plutôt une énergie décuplée par ce que
dans la rue je ne vois personne me
traiter de nazi ni fasciste mais plein
de gens qui me vaut continuer c'est
formidable je suis pas d'accord avec
bien sûr tous mais c'est bien ce que
vous faites je me suis abonné à votre
revue jeunes abonnés à votre rue etc
et s'il faut choisir entre l'assentiment
de personnage corrompu dont bernard lévy
ou l'assentiment d'un chauffeur de taxi
ou de donc de deux dindes un serveur la
terrasse d'un café où et c'est mon choix
est fait j'ai effectivement une
préférence pour l'assentiment du peuple
plutôt pour la simulation qui vont de
ceux qui méprisent les peu une chose est
sûre nous sommes dans un climat
extrêmement tendu aujourd'hui on sort de
cette crise on en est sortie totalement
d'ailleurs sanitaire il ya eu ces
manifestations anti raciste anti
violence policière clairement et ça sera
ma dernière question michel onfray et
at-il aujourd'hui une fracture entre
l'état et le peuple il ya une mignonne
guerre civile qui est évidente qui ne
dit pas son nom c'est à dire que l'état
fait semblant de pas voir sa vessie de
ses trois petits singes l'aller
maintenant les yeux les mains dans les
oreilles et maintenant la bouche pas vu
pas entendu on ne dit rien ne se passe
rien chacun voit bien effectivement
qu'il y a une centaine d'endroits en
france où la république ne fait plus la
loi et quand vous avez un ministre de
l'intérieur qui vous dit que après tout
l'émotion est plus importante que la loi
alors c'est fini c'est terminé quand
vous êtes un ministre de l'intérieur qui
dit je suis prêt à mettre un genou à
terre alors qu'il est déjà un ventre à
terre qu'il ait déjà accouché
bien évident que tout est fini que plus
rien n'existe dans cet état français
donc on est dans une dans une situation
effectivement de guerre civile je je
crains que nous basculions un jour ou le
sang va couler il ya un moment donné
quelqu'un va tirer dans le tas il va y
avoir une grenade dégoupillée ou dans la
salle de kalachnikovs et alors là plus
rien mais c'est peut-être ne sera
tenable
parce que le chef de l'état n'est pas
crédible parce que l'état a perdu toute
autorité et parce que on crache sur la
police qui fait un métier terriblement
difficile la police et l'interpellent
c'est son métier d'interpeller les gens
dangereux agressif violent et armés donc
si on estime qu' il faut faire ce métier
juste avec des avec des ddd petit modo
des bisounours ou des petits post it
avec vous non mais vous n'aurez pas ma
haine ça va pas marcher
si vous avez une violence illégale
illégitime
il y a dans un état normalement une
violence légale et légitime
c'est le monopole de la violence légale
c'est la définition de max de berre la
police et l'armée sont là pour ça et on
est en train de déligitimer la violence
légale
en dix ans les policiers sont dans la
violence dans l'agressivité sont des
fascistes etc
et puis en face on vient maintenant les
autres ils n'ont rien fait alors que la
plupart du temps tout toutes ces
affaires elle concerne des gens qui sont
des voleurs des trafiquants qui nous est
quasi judiciaire etc
merci merci beaucoup michel en fait on
arrive à la fin de notre entretien la
foule avoir accordé en direct sur rt
france et on espère avoir établi voilà
quelques intentions sur votre revue qui
est sorti cette semaine déjà 26 mille
abonnements pour cette revue est
ressorti
merci à vous à michel onfray rester avec
nous dans quelques instants
être d'un rebond de 40 europe et puis en
france olivier ferrand qui annonce lui
une campagne de tests virologiques de
très grande ampleur
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
merci nous rejoindre penser à deuxième
heure d'émission il est 21h heure de
paris voici les titres de l'actualité de
ce jeudi 25 juin une campagne de tests
virologiques de grande ampleur telle est
la stratégie d'olivier ferrand pour
identifier les foyers de contamination
dormant liés aux coronavirus alors que
les auditions de la commission d'
enquête parlementaire au lendemain de
celle du professeur dia raul se
poursuivre
l'élysée charge lui une mission
indépendante d'évaluer la gestion de la
crise un premier rapport est attendu à
l'automne
c'est un rapport accablant pour ursula
von der leyen celui de l'opposition
allemande elle accuse de la désormais
présidente de la commission européenne
d'avoir mal géré le ministère allemand
de la défense quand elle était à la tête
quand elle était à sa tête pire encore
l'opposition la soupçonne d'avoir
dilapidé des dizaines de millions
d'euros en payant des consultants or des
procédures régulières de contrôle
donald trump a annoncé qu'il y à peu
retiré ses soldats del male le locataire
de la maison blanche a affirmé hier
qu'il comptait diriger une partie de ce
contingent vers la pologne
une annonce faite alors que le président
polonais qui briguera un deuxième mandat
dans quelques jours était précisément à
washington les juges de la chambre
d'appel de la cour pénale internationale
ont entamé leur délibéré ils doivent
statuer sur la demande de la procureur
fatou bensouda qui s'opposaient
l'acquittement de l'ex président
ivoirien laurent gbagbo et de son
ministre charles blé goudé tous deux
accusés de crimes contre l'humanité lors
de la crise post électorale en côte
d'ivoire 2
2010 et 2011
[Musique]
et on commence par le point sur les
chiffres du cordat virus dans l'hexagone
le nombre de cas graves en réanimation
poursuit sa baisse avec 651 malades soit
7 de moins par rapport à hier
selon la direction générale de la santé
la france enregistre 21 morts liés aux
convives 19 dans les hôpitaux ces
dernières 24 heures au total 29 mille
sept cent cinquante deux personnes sont
décédées depuis le début de l'épidémie
et alors que les manifestations se
multiplient depuis le des confirmands le
ministre de la santé appelle à éviter
les grands rassemblements et le
comportement à risques annonce
aujourd'hui dans un entretien au journal
le monde
il évoque également une campagne de
tests virologiques et de grande ampleur
pour identifier les éventuels cluster
dormant concernés 1,3 million
d'habitants dans 30 communes d'île de
france notamment une expérimentation sur
la base du volontariat qui pourra
ensuite être étendu à d'autres régions
olivier ferrand on le rappelle a proposé
hier 6 milliards d'euros pour les
hausses de salaires des soignants partir
du 1er juillet annonce accueillie
timidement par les syndicats un mois
après le lancement du ségur de la santé
et pour en parler pour parler de la
gestion de la crise du coronavirus en
france alors que l'om est dit
s'inquiéter d'un rebond du nombre de cas
en europe
nous sommes en direct avec bertrand
legrand médecins généralistes catherine
hill épidémiologiste
bonsoir à tous les deux merci d'être
avec nous alors une une réaction à tout
d'abord peut-être sur ce qu'on a appris
cet après midi l'elysée qui charge une
mission indépendante d'évaluer à la
gestion de la crise sanitaire c'est une
bonne chose
bertrand legrand est bien fait comme
toujours il va surtout falloir savoir
qui est dans la commission parce que si
on fait une commission avec des
personnes qui n'ont pas une indépendance
parfaite
ce sera compliqué donc
faire des commissions c'est bien agir
c'est mieux madame catherine hill c'est
pas vraiment le moment on est encore en
plein dans la fin de la première vague
cette première vague n'est pas fini donc
on verra plus tard pour faire les
comptes et dire qu'il est on aurait pu
faire mieux et comme on aurait pu faire
mieux mais voilà je suis moi ça
m'intéresse pas beaucoup ça alors ça
vous intéresse pas mais tout de même il
ya quand même un voilà un soupçon qui
flotte dans l'air on a écouté évidemment
l'audition du didier raoul hier qui
voilà qui évoquer davantage de
politiques moins de 6 ans didier raoul
qui alliait qui elle est assez fort qui
a visé les conflits d'intérêts les
laboratoire gilead notamment ça vous a
surpris vous bertrand legrand
j'avoue que les histoires de cons fils
de laboratoire moi je fais pas partie de
ceux qui jettent la pierre aux
laboratoires ou inversement qui sont des
aficionados des de la pureté absolue
je pense que les laboratoires ont tout
intérêt à ce que si on s'avance et donc
du coup par définition ils s'adressent à
des spécialistes et ses histoires de il
faut absolument de plus ne plus avoir
aucun lien avec les laboratoires nous
ont conduit à supprimer toutes les
capacités de formation de nos internes
et qui aujourd'hui peine bien avoir les
subsides de l'état pour obtenir le
financement de leur formation donc
l'état veut supprimer les subsides des
laboratoires sait très bien qu'ils
payent à sa place et là on se sera
parfait 1 catherine hill sur ce point
mais c'est évident que les essais de des
traitements ont été catastrophiques en
france qu'en fond on n'a pas beaucoup de
résultats à mettre sur la table
on peut comparer à ce qu'ont fait les
anglais ils ont fait un grand et sec
auquel ils ont testé plusieurs
traitements et ils nous ont apporté
plusieurs résultats que la dexaméthasone
est utile et que l'hydroxyde chloroquine
à l'hôpital n'est pas vraiment utile
donc voilà il va falloir effectivement
faire le bilan de ça et penser à
réorganiser la façon de faire les études
de médicaments et le professeur out a
démontré une compétence absolue dans
l'évaluation des médicaments ou bertrand
legrand vous vous partagez ce constat un
petit peu sévère d'incompétence
totalement dans l'évaluation des
médicaments il ya vraiment eu
voilà des failles dans ce système
d'études selon vous également il suffit
de regarder le résultat qui est produit
aujourd'hui qu'elle aimait de la
médecine française a produit ces aucune
résultats scientifiques
on s'est contenté d'un débat politique
trop où on tira hoult complètement
stérile qui sert à rien et voilà on a
deux camps d'ayatollahs qui s'affrontent
les uns les autres et qui ne du coup ne
produisent ni dans un sens ni dans un
autre
aujourd'hui clairement parle d'une
deuxième vague on va pas citer
effectivement didier raoul toutes les
deux minutes mais c'est vrai qu'il nous
avait prédit voilà ce départ du virus
que le virus circule rem équlibrée
l'épidémie partir est bon maintenant il
est envisagé qu'elle revienne avec la
nouvelle zélande catherine ils vont vous
c'est toujours aussi inquiètes plus que
jamais je dirais je suis pas très
inquiète mais l'épidémie n'est pas
terminée donc on peut pas faire comme si
l'épidémie était fini il ya encore 500
cas par jour à peu près et on a vu que à
pékin après avoir eu zéro cas pendant
quatre semaines
tout d'un coup il ya eu de nouveaux 30
cas par jour et on a fait très attention
confiné tester s'est désinfecté et c'est
ici on a 500 cas partout et tout le
monde s'en fiche complètement
donc l'épidémie n'est pas finie la
première vague n'est pas fini le virus
est là bertrand legrand votre diagnostic
également c'était une plusieurs fois
alors là c'est vrai que la première fois
vous parliez de votre cabinet vous me
disiez ben voila j'ai plus de cas en
ville la semaine d'après vous étiez un
peu plus mesurée qu'en est il
aujourd'hui vous avez quand même
l'impression aujourd'hui qu'il ya un
frein dans cette épidémie où vous restez
prudents et même inquiet contrairement à
la mine moi je n'ai la vision que de mon
propre cabinet donc forcément ma vision
est très limité à un quartier donc je ne
peux pas avoir une
vision qui soit au niveau national ce
qui est certain c'est que manifestement
les chiffres montrent qu'effectivement
là de la première vague n'a pas été
terminé
et quand on sait que le l'épidémie est
partie de quelques cas c'est toujours
inquiétant de se dire qu'on relâche la
politique de test simple fait que nous
avons trop peu de mes de trop peu de
positif sur le nombre de tests que nous
faisons et on a l'impression d'être sur
un concours du de celui du pays qui aura
le plus de positif alors là dessus on
est gagnant parce qu'on fait tellement
peu de tests qu'on arrive à avoir plein
de positif
on est super fort mais on est super
inutile surtout alors vous allez être
quand même contents tous les deux olives
et veyran a évoqué une campagne de tests
virologiques de grande ampleur pour
identifier d éventuels cluster dormant
1,3 million de personnes sont concernées
dans 30 communes
manifestement seulement d'île de france
catherine hill vous êtes satisfait tout
s'est encore pas trop la bonne solution
pour vous à ce qu est la bonne solution
c'est de tester massivement la
population
le fond du problème c'est qu'il ya
énormément de alors verrons il parle de
clusters dormant ça c'est un truc qui
l'a inventé je ne sais pas qu'est ce que
c'est que cette histoire
le sascoc 2 est un virus qui a la
propriété d'infecter des gens qui
restent asymptomatique et qui sont
contagieux la règle de base d'une
maladie infectieuse qu'il faut trouver
des gens qui sont contagieux pour les
isoler pour qu'ils évitent qui contamine
d'autres gens et pour trouver ces gens
qui n'ont pas de symptômes
la seule façon c'est de tester tout le
monde c'est ça qui a été fait dans un
sens à tout le monde autour dans les
régions où on a une petite chance de
tomber sera porteur du virus par exemple
en ile de france
donc c'est une très bonne idée de tester
tout le monde en ile de france c'est
juste un peu tard mais jamais trop tard
pour bien faire
donc on va tester en ile-de-france assez
massivement dans les communes où il ya
plus de chances d'avoir des porteurs de
virus
on pourrait tester encore plus largement
ça va peut-être venir
bertrand legrand j'ai souvent entendu
dire bon bah voilà les tests les masques
on les a maintenant face
peut-être bon pour la prochaine fois
c'est bien ça effectivement de tester
sur l'île de france est la bonne
stratégie d'olivier vers 1 la première
stratégie c'était de faire du trail du
contact racing et donc j'imagine que
tous les personnes en charge du contact
racing ont prescrit des tests et ce
qu'on aimerait bien savoir c'est le taux
de tests réalisés par rapport au nombre
de taux de tests prescrits et de ce que
j'en sais on n'atteint pas le niveau de
ce qu'on peut avoir nous en cabine et
quand on demande à la personne elle vous
voulez vous être testés et consorts
l'écouvillon et qu on le teste donc
circuits courts on a un taux à 100%
organisations étatiques
on aura un taux à 40 50 60 % donc la
meilleure méthode pour tester un grand
nombre de personnes c'est de fournir les
tests aux médecins généralistes de les
inciter à tester et d'organiser le
circuit de collecte des données pour
donner aux épidémiologistes les
résultats mais si on gratte une seule de
ces pistes on rate ou alors que si on
fait des surnoms prescrit des tests mais
qu'ils sont pas fait ça sert à rien et
si on fait des tests et que c'est pas
donné aux épidémiologistes et qu'on en
reste au stade de notre cabinet ça sert
aussi à rien donc voilà ça fait trois
mois qu'on essaie de s'organiser dans
six mois on sera prêt de six mois
peut-être la date malheureusement de la
deuxième vague catherine hill vous vous
avez bien précisé que pour vous la
première vague n'était pas terminée mais
cette fameuse deuxième vague un peu
virulente en octobre en octobre c'est
souvent ce qui est ce qui est dit en
tout cas à l'automne vous vous y croyez
ou vous pouvez un petit peu nous
rassurer ce soir ben je peux ni vous
rassurer ni vous alarmer je vois pas
pourquoi l'épidémie ne reprendrait pas
fin juillet ou en août
si le virus est toujours là et si les
gens bougent pas mal ne font plus du
tout attention et en plus de chance en
bougeant de rencontrer des gens qui
n'ont pas rencontré la semaine dernière
et donc c'est comme un billet acheté
plus de billets de loterie plus vous
rencontrer des gens différents plus en
plus le risque vous avez le risque de
tomber sur un quai porter est contagieux
donc c'est
le truc on peut pas du tout dans
l'histoire de haute pourquoi l'automne
on a vraiment c'est parce que les gens
pensent que ce virus
et comme les virus de la grippe et qu'il
est saisonnier mais vu qu'ils adulent il
ya eu du virus depuis l'islande jusqu'à
hong kong nouvelle zélande qui les
honore de la musique d'amérique du nord
autant qu'en amérique du sud
je vois vraiment pas où la saison est
complètement à l'envers je vois vraiment
pas qu'est ce qui permet de dire que ce
virus serait saisonniers je vois
beaucoup le monde f1 vous sur cette
deuxième vague à l'automne annoncé fric
te ment possible peut pas y avoir de
deuxième vague en doute je pars en
vacances
non mais effectivement toujours en voilà
la même chose des masques les tests les
gestes barrière c'est ce qui nous
prémunir à bertrand legrand et ça sera
le mot de la fin pour vous oui faut
vraiment enfin faut continuer les gestes
barrière vraiment faim que chacun soit
raisonnable sur la question tant qu'on
n'a pas une à deux semaines sans aucun
test positif
évidemment qu'il faut continuer à avoir
des gestes barrières les masques et
mettez vos masques évidemment quand vous
êtes dans un lieu confiné et ne le
retire et pas quand vous rentrez dans le
cabinet du médecin c'est si possible par
des c'est promis bertrand legrand vous
laissera partir en vacances merci
également à vous catherine hill d'avoir
été en direct avec nous sur rt france
merci à vous deux un départ précipité
pour bruxelles qui interroge dans le
viseur de la presse outre-rhin la
présidente de la commission européenne
ursula von der leyen en poste depuis
bientôt un an
l'ancien ministre de la défense
allemande est vivement critiquée
aujourd'hui dans un rapport rédigé par
les députés issus de l'opposition sa
gestion du ministère de 2013 à 2019 est
décrite comme un échec complet avec des
2 millions d'euros mal dépensé pour des
consultants conseiller ou encore autres
sous traitants privés
une commission d enquête parlementaire a
été depuis ouverte ses conclusions
définitives devraient être rendues la
semaine prochaine et pour en parler
nous sommes en direct avec françois
poulet mathis journalistes spécialistes
europe bonsoir françois boulay mathis
merci d'être avec nous alors
concrètement qu on essaye d'y voir plus
clair que reproche-t-on à ursula von der
leyen
on lui reproche lorsqu'elle était
ministre de la défense c'est à dire en
charge de la bundeswehr d'avoir fait
appel à des cabinets privés à des
consultants sans véritable considération
des sommes qui étaient demandés et donc
c'est une centaine de millions qui sont
directement en cause de consultants
privés qui seraient intervenus sans
qu'elle apparemment elle en est le
contrôle au moins c'est ce qu'elle dit
pour se défendre
c'est quand même grave dans la mesure où
ces cabinets privés laisse passer l'idée
que le ministère de la défense est à
dire un ministère régalien seraient
infiltrés par des intérêts qui ne sont
pas des intérêts d'état et donc là la
critique et est ennuyeuse pour ursula
von der leyen
cela dit on connaissait cette critique
au moment où elle est partie à bruxelles
est précisément d'ailleurs les allemands
considéré qu' angela merkel d'une
certaine manière lui avait donné une
porte de sortie de protection en
envoyant à bruxelles ce qui permettait
relativement de la protéger donc elle
est vraiment sûr sur le grill elle est
sur le grill mais il faut peut-être
assemble vous l'avez signalé d'ailleurs
de rire de la conclusion de la
commission denquête qui réunit
opposition et majorité et donc qui
réunit le parti d'angela merkel avec
l'opposition qui jusqu'à maintenant
était la seule à l'avoir mis en cause
donc il faut voir ce que ça va donner
effectivement d'ici une semaine je ne
pense pas que ça puisse remettre en
cause son poste à la commission mais il
faut quand même dire que le démarrage de
mandat de ursula von der leyen était pas
facile pas facile parce qu'elle est
partie de manière assez précipité du
ministère de la défense alors qu'elle
était promise à de grandes destinées on
même on lui prédisait même eu un poste
de chancelière à la limite
et puis cette affaire-là effectivement
là un petit peu plombé et puis son
démarrage à bruxelles n'a pas été non
plus très concluants dans la mesure où
les députés européens espéraient avoir
un candidat à la présidence de la
commission qui soit le reflet de la
majorité acquise aux élections
européennes et donc en l'occurrence
c'était le socialiste dit herman ce qui
devait arriver or là ursula von der
leyen a été le fruit d'un compromis
entre emmanuel macron et angela merkel
donc elle est arrivée dans des
conditions qui n'étaient pas des
conditions optimales le dernier obstacle
et qui n'est pas le moine c'était que
compte tenu du fait que l'allemagne a
démarré assez tard le virus le corps
navires us et dans des conditions
beaucoup plus favorables que ça a été le
cas en italie en espagne et bien ce fait
la donne et la pression que ursula von
der leyen une fois la commission était
plus allemande que présidente de la
commission donc elle n'a pas
véritablement mesurer l'importance de ce
coronavirus et l'importance de la
pandémie qui arrive et si bien qu'elle a
agi un petit peu en retard la commission
agit en retard elle a été finalement au
coeur de ce reproche que l'on a fait à
la commission de ne pas avoir été tout
de suite au manettes pour éviter ce
dérapage ce désordre auquel on a assisté
au démarrage de la pandémie
alors les partisans un d'ursula von der
leyen estiment eux qui n'étaient pas au
courant des irrégularités dans
l'attribution de missions de conseil
alors s'interroge on peut se poser la
question est ce possible quand un
ministre ne soit pas au courant de ce
qui se passe au sein son propre
ministère c'est toute la question c'est
toute la question est de quelle
confiance peut elle bénéficier dans les
proclamations de bonne foi qu'est là en
disant qu' elle n'avait n'était
absolument pas au courant parce que
c'était pas de son niveau ce qui est
quand même relativement grave parce que
voir des cabinets privés qui s'empare
d'une certaine manière de consulter de
consultants de poste de consultant pour
des questions relativement stratégique
c'est quand même inquiétant pour un
ministère de la défense qui je le
rappelle est quand même un ministère
régalien en allemagne donc on peu aussi
mais effectivement que cette affaire
n'est pas terminée
cela dit je pense que la semaine
prochaine lorsqu'on aura les résultats
de l' enquête conjointe
opposition et majorité peut-être que les
choses vont se clarifier un petit peu
dans la mesure où angela merkel est bien
décidé à défendre coûte que coûte sa
candidate qui est urgent de lavardens
dia alors à tout de même louis
effectivement les ça devrait être rendu
de la semaine prochaine est ce que ça
pourrait al'inverse donner des
conséquences judiciaires
c'est possible mais il faudra prouver
c'est toujours le problème des preuves
photos et quelles preuves
est ce que véritablement elle n'était
pas au courant et ça c'est une véritable
enquête judiciaire qui doit être mené en
allemagne
cela dit c'est vrai que étant à
bruxelles elle est relativement protégé
donc elle a un poste qui la protège
c'est un petit peu d'ailleurs ce qu'on
lui avait reproché c'est d'aller à
bruxelles sous forme de fuite en quelque
sorte mais ça ne peut pas s'exprimer
pour l'instant il faudra que l'enquêté
aille plus loin pour l'instant cette
affaire fait beaucoup de bruit parce que
je le rappelle c'est l'opposition les
verts notamment
c'est eux qui émettent en avance cette
culpabilité évalué de lancieux laroque
d'asian donc c'est pas encore prouvé
cette affaire n'aura ses suites
en tout cas à l'ombre du soupçon jamais
bon effectivement pour une réputation la
commission européenne peut-être se
permettre d'avoir à sa tête quelqu'un
soupçonnés de fraude
oui il ya eu des cas semblables dans le
passé on a vu des commissaires et pas
des moindres qui ont connu comme ça des
situations appliquée dans des cabinets
de consulting note avant un petit peu le
même genre de situation ça peut se veut
ça peut se produire
en attendant la commission à européenne
je le rappelle c'est quand même une
structure qui est européenne et qui est
donc au-delà des pays au delà des partis
ou l'inde et pays
et donc pour qu'une commission pour
qu'une enquête puisse la toucher
directement
il faut effectivement que les services
de la commission soit directement engagé
et a monté une enquête eux de leur côté
effectivement pour essayer de mettre
sous la dent des layènes devant
d'éventuelles contradictions mais pour
l'instant c'est encore trop tôt pour le
dire
merci françois paul et mathis d'avoir
été avec nous en direct sur rt francs en
somme et en russe en russie à présent au
lendemain des commémorations de la
victoire sur l'allemagne nazie
place au référendum constitutionnel la
consultation commence aujourd'hui
jusqu'au 1er juillet scrutin étalé sur
la longueur pour éviter une trop forte
affluence endémique coronavirus oblige
les rues se prononce pour entériner ou
non un ensemble de réformes de la
constitution
parmi les mesures la possibilité pour
vladimir poutine d'effectuer deux
mandats présidentiels supplémentaires à
partir de 2024 david khalifa en janvier
dernier le président russe surprend tout
le monde en proposant d'apporter des
amendements à la constitution
quelques heures après cette annonce le
gouvernement décide de démissionner la
constitution actuelle date de 1993 et a
été mise en place sous boris eltsine
élaboré sur les décombres de l'ère
soviétique
elle est l'objet de critiques dues à
l'hyper présidentialisation du jeu
politique qu'elle induit c'est aussi une
constitution qui n'est dans le sang à
l'époque le parlement contrôlé par les
communistes hostiles au projet tente de
destituer helsinn pour rester au pouvoir
il fait appel à l'armée 187 personnes
sont tuées durant cet automne l'un des
objectifs principaux de ce changement de
constitution et donc de mettre fin à ce
système tout en conservant intactes les
bases de la constitution à l'heure
actuelle seul le président peut nommer
le chef du gouvernement et les ministres
le parlement donne juste son feu vert
formel le changement proposé renforcera
le pouvoir du parlement qui aura le
dernier mot concernant la composition du
gouvernement tandis que le président ne
sera pas en mesure de s'y opposer les
pouvoirs seront ainsi redistribués entre
les différentes branches
afin d'équilibrer le système de
gouvernance russe un autre changement
important porte sur la limitation des
mandats présidentiels à deux au total au
lieu de deux mandats consécutifs
actuellement
cela implique que les futurs chefs
d'état ne pourront pas rester au pouvoir
aussi longtemps que vladimir poutine
un changement qui obnubile les médias
occidentaux selon les règles existantes
à vladimir poutine
elle doit partir dans quatre ans à la
fin de son second mandat consécutif
son quatrième au total les membres du
parlement ont néanmoins proposé de
remettre à zéro le compteur de ses
mandats avec des amendements
je propose soit de lever la limitation
du nombre de mandats présidentiels soin
d'inclure dans un article du projet de
loi une clause permettant au président
actuel
une fois que la constitution modifiée
sera entrée en vigueur de se porter
candidat à l'élection présidentielle
comme à tout autre citoyen cela signifie
que poutine pourra se porter candidat en
2024 et en 2030 s'ils le souhaitent
pour vladimir poutine ces changements
dans la constitution vise à mettre en
place un état providence nash notre
tâche commune la plus importante est de
faire en sorte que les résultats du
référendum soit absolument incontestable
et légitime légitimé les minimes et
quatre amis vous savez j'avais déjà
parlé à plusieurs reprises dans
l'ensemble ces amendements à la
constitution n'exigeait pas et n'exige
pas selon là où en vigueur
l'organisation d'un référendum mais j'ai
estimé qu'il était très important pour
que les gens expriment directement leurs
opinions sur les amendements proposés ce
maillot primeau et internationaux que
tempo peur comme catho le prix de
longues heures il y à plus de 140
amendements l'un de garantie que le
salaire minimum ne peut pas être
inférieur au coût de la vie un autre
changement consacre la primauté du droit
russe sur le droit international
certaines propositions font l'objet de
débats
par exemple le mariage sera uniquement
considérée comme l'union entre un homme
et une femme dieu sera également
mentionné même si la russie restera un
état laïque est des propositions qui
sont soumises à un référendum
les modifications seront donc adopter
uniquement si les sites
doyen russes les approuvent on reste
avec nous dans quelques instants nous
partirons aux états unis donald trump a
annoncé le retrait des troupes
américaines d'allemagne une partie
devrait être transféré en polonais puis
direction la et où l'ancien président
ivoirien laurent gbagbo devra encore
attendre pour être fixé sur son sort
suite à l'appel déposé contre son
équipement
[Musique]
l'état a mis sur la table une série de
mesures pour aider le secteur 18
milliards d'euros pour le tourisme là
pour l'instant via les aides encore les
aides et donc que les choses vont se
compliquer à la rentrée bon ok ça parle
beaucoup mais qu'il faut il faut du
concret et les fonds de solidarité de
1500 euros et ses terrasses et des
pacotilles tout ça c'est c'est mal fait
c'est mal préparée donc comment voulez
vous que les gens s'ils troupes le plus
dur c'est à venir et c'est là où pour
l'armement contrôler ça va être
compliqué de faire revenir les gens pour
la bonne et simple raison qu'on a tous
perdu beaucoup de revenus
donc de toute façon on est on est dans
une impasse
[Musique]
si on écoute ceux qui ne sont pas
d'accord
[Musique]
ici qu'on invite les plus compétents pas
seulement ceux qui parlent le plus fort
[Musique]
ici on reçoit ce qu'on voit pas ailleurs
parce qu'ici c'est interdit d'interdire
[Musique]
pourquoi vous maintenez le traitement à
base d'hydroquinone rockin et d'asie
trop mis 6 malgré la polémique mondiale
sur l'efficacité de cette combinaison la
même manière nous avions déjà commencé à
utiliser le protocole avec les boutiques
préoccupe bien avant que le match ne
commence son déchet par sénégal la
chloroquine domaniale est utilisé
pendant des décennies et des décennies
ça promet peyresourde laisser la galère
quand j'entends de nice les rennais n'y
a pas de signes qui m'est rendu
voilà ce que j'ai trouvé
[Musique]
on
l'histoire est plus compliquée que
certains veulent nous faire croire
vouloir à la réécrire pour faire oublier
les échecs ne permet pas de comprendre
ce qui s'est vraiment passé
c'est ainsi que dans certains manuels de
cours d'histoire de nos enfants on veut
faire oublier napoléon bonaparte grand
organisateur de l'état moderne au profit
de robespierre
le père de la terreur j'ai écouté le
président très pratique et le déni en
oubliant carrément l'allier qui a eu le
triste privilège d'avoir le plus grand
nombre de morts dans la deuxième guerre
mondiale
mais si j'ai bien compris ils sont morts
pour rien puisque au nom d'une idéologie
on nie leur existence en oubliant une
partie de la game
[Musique]
est-ce qu'on a une idée de
l'augmentation ou pas des signes ici
d'aujourd'hui en france les cours et les
violences existait avant le confinement
et pendant ce confinement c'est vrai
qu'il ya sept ce cadre lecture les dos
de féminicide a plus que je dis pas
doublé mais bien monté
forcément on n'a pas encore tous les
chiffres officiels c'est très difficile
braun et jamais des âmes et loi a
finalement c'est le confinement dans le
confinement
cela veut dire qu'il ya huit clos au
sein des foyers
et forcément dans les femmes victimes de
violences de nombreux mois à 3
[Musique]
21h30 soyez les bienvenus en direct sur
rt france des soldats américains seront
à prochainement envoyée en pologne
c'est l'annoncé faite par le président
américain hier alors que les relations
entre donald trump et angela merkel sont
tendues washington se rapproche
désormais de la pologne françois tessier
beach partir d'allemagne pour la pologne
c'est l'annnonce de donald trump alors
qu'il recevait à la maison blanche son
homologue polonais andrezj duda nous
allons réunir nos forces en allemagne
certains rentreront à la maison d'autres
iront ailleurs mais la pologne sera l'un
de ses autres endroits ces autres
endroits en europe
aucun détail sur les chiffre n'a été
donné mais cette annonce intervient dans
un contexte de tension entre les états
unis l'allemagne
il y a quelques jours le président
américain avait évoqué la diminution des
troupes américaines basées en allemagne
de 52000 à 25 mille hommes
reprochant notamment à berlin des
impayés dans sa contribution à l'otan
l'allemagne sont des délinquants ce sont
les délinquants depuis des années ça
fait des années qu'ils ont des arriérés
et ils doivent des milliards de dollars
à l'otan il faut qu'il paie une présence
américaine en allemagne importante pour
la sécurité américaine et européenne
avait déclaré en réponse le lendemain le
ministre allemand des affaires
étrangères
ce mercredi depuis des jardins de la
maison blanche le président polonais a
assuré qu'il n'avait pas demandé à
donald trump de transférer les troubles
dans son pays mais avoue lui avoir
demandé de ne pas retirer de soldats
américains d'europe
mais alors le transfert des soldats
américains d'allemagne vers la pologne
pourrait-il avoir une influence sur la
présidentielle la réponse avec gérald
olivier chercheur à l'institut
prospective et sécurité en europe
spécialiste des etats-unis alors le seul
coup politique pourrait être lié au fait
qu'il fasse rentrer les soldats aux
états unis parce que parmi les promesses
de campagne de donald trump en 2016
il y avait celle de terminer ces
conflits lointains en irak en
afghanistan et ailleurs de cessé de
déployer des soldats américains sur tous
les théâtres hostiles à travers le monde
et de faire en sorte qu'il rentre au
bercail là
et pas tout à fait ce qu'il a indiqué il
a indiqué qu' il allait déplacer
dix mille soldats environ d'allemagne
sans doute vers la pologne donc c'est
certain seront rapatriés aux états unis
d'autres sans doute la moitié seront
déployés en pologne
on ne sait pas encore où mais
apparemment la pologne est d'accord pour
payer le loyer et l'entretien de ses
bases donc donald trump ferait une
certaine économie le coup pour moi elle
n'est pas si électorale que ça parce que
les américains ne regarde pas de si près
la politique étrangère de leur président
par contre s'il peut dire j'ai promis de
faire rentrer les soldats à la maison et
j'ai tenu ma promesse ça suffira pour
lui pour avoir un argument de campagne
de plus et pour en parler nous sommes en
direct depuis budapest avec hadj orge
samu eddy chercheur au global policy
institute c'est notre rubrique vu de
l'extérieur ce soit
[Musique]
bonsoir je lui dis merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt francs savoir
pourquoi cette coopération militaire
avec la pologne la pologne est un ami
fiable pour donald trump
oui donald trump en a pas beaucoup en
europe 1 ce moment notamment l'allemagne
n'est pas vraiment une grande amie donc
ils aiment l'idée de glorifier la
pologne qui correspond qui remplit ses
obligations par exemple en matière de
portions du bébé consacrées aux dépenses
militaires contrairement à l'allemagne
contrairement à l'allemagne la pologne
achète du gaz naturel liquéfié aux états
unis alors que l'allemagne achète son
gaz naturel à la russie a grâce au
gazoduc nord stream 2 et bien sûr cela
irrite fortement donald trump
il a également peut-être un peu de
sympathie politique envers le
gouvernement conservateur du président
tout à alors ce déplacement de troupes
vers la pologne
est ce qu'on peut y voir un message pour
la russie effectivement la russie n'en
n'est pas très contente
on pourrait dire que cela viole l'acte
fondateur des relations entre l'otan et
la russie qui interdit tout
redéploiement majeur de troupes sur le
continent européen
mais un redéploiement des forces
aura-t-il vraiment lieu vers la pologne
on peut se poser la question
difficile de dire si elle est 9508 avons
vraiment être bien retiré d'allemagne
ils menacent de le faire mais donald
trump n'a pas encore fait et la pologne
devraient payer beaucoup d'argent sans
doute plusieurs milliards de dollars 2
milliards de dollars pour accueillir ses
troupes et la question c'est est-ce que
ils ont cet argent au vu de la crise de
la pandémie et la pologne n'a pas grand
chose en matière d'infrastructures qui
permettrait d'accueillir les troupes
américaines contrairement à l'allemagne
donc on ne sait pas vraiment si cela va
arriver et on ne sait pas quel nombre de
militaires seront déployés vers la
pologne
alors quelle peut être la réaction de
moscou la russie est très mécontente
vis-à-vis de beaucoup mais de nombreuses
et cision de l'otan par exemple les
manoeuvres à proximité de la frontière
russe et l'expansion constante de l'otan
qui a accepté de plus en plus de membres
et sans oublier bien sûr le rôle de
l'otan lors du conflit de crime et
notamment et concernant le traité fmi ou
le traité s'il ouvert donc la russie
elle n'est pas très contente de tout
cela la ligne à ne pas franchir seraient
les armes nucléaires les armes
nucléaires sont explicitement interdite
par l'acte fondateur entre l'otan et la
russie il ne peut pas y avoir de
déploiement d'armes nucléaires dans
cette région et certains hommes
politiques pensent à supprimer des
aux armes nucléaires sur le sol allemand
en tout cas ce serait la ligne rouge
pour la russie alors on le rappelle
quand même en retirant ses troupes
d'allemagne donald trump voulait en
quelque sorte punir entre guillemets les
allemands pour leur budget de défense
insuffisant mais aussi peut-être pour le
gazoduc nord stream 2 on peut dire cela
oui je le pense
le gazoduc north stream ii a fortement
irrité donald trump car donald trump a
pour fond de commerce la vente des
produits américains et ce gaz naturel
liquéfié est un produit phare
donc il est vraiment énervé parce que
l'allemagne se tourner vers la russie
bien que bien sûr c'est bien moins cher
pour l'allemagne que le gnl américain il
n'a pas de très bonnes relations avec la
chancelière allemande angela merkel
récemment madame merkel a dit qu'elle ne
participerait pas au sommet organisé aux
états unis et donald trump a des idées
tranche l'europe en général ils
imaginent que les états unis paix pour
la défense de l'union européenne et que
l'europe n'a aucune reconnaissance pour
lui l'otan a sa place dans un musée
c'est une relique historique et d'un
point de vue start à moins de vue la
raison
il a des idées très très archaïque sur
la relation entre les etats-unis et
l'europe
merci à georges samedi d'avoir été avec
nous en direct sur arte france pour vu
de l'extérieur ce soir trois jours
d'audition qui se sont achevés
aujourd'hui
car même à la haye aux pays-bas laurent
gbagbo ex président de la côte d'ivoire
et son ministre charles blé goudé ont
comparu devant la cour pénale
internationale pour crimes contre
l'humanité juges avocats et greffiers
ont entamé leur délibéré qui ne devrait
pas être rendu avant longtemps série
élevé la vitesse bull plus comme un
sentiment de fermeté en ce début de
semaine à la cour pénale internationale
de la haye cette impression la salle la
doit à la procureur fatou bensouda qui a
demandé un procès en appel à la suite d
acquittement de laurent gbagbo et
charles blé goudé en janvier 2019
les deux ex dirigeants ivoiriens sont
accusés d'avoir perpétré des massacres
en 2010 et 2011
lors des violences post électorales qui
avaient coûté la vie à trois mille
personnes
les deux hommes avaient été reconnus non
coupables de crimes contre l'humanité
par erreur la chambre de première
instance a commis une erreur en
acquittant monsieur gbagbo et monsieur
les guider en violation de ses
obligations fondamentales au titre de
l'article 74 5 vs c'est fait et d'autres
faits objectifs vont tous dans le même
sens
la majorité n'a pas achevé l'exercice de
raisonnement complet requis par
l'article 74
au moment où elle a été acquittée
oralement en janvier 2019 des auditions
partiellement virtuel en raison de la
crise sanitaire lié aux coronavirus les
juges ont entamé un délibéré pour savoir
si un procès en appel doit bien avoir
lieu
le seul moyen selon les victimes de ces
crises ivoiriennes que justice soit
rendue mais rien n'est joué
imprimé à l'issue possible qu'ils aient
souhaité balaie pas besoin de visas long
ruban beau ça qu'il n'y ait pas de suite
favorable à cette demande formulée par
mme bensouda et donc que le pneu
vous savez vous déçoit quitté qu'il
puisse regagner la côte d'ivoire de
notre côté il ya la possibilité au style
que la cour estime que la demande
formulée par madame des dessous des
récits vannes et donc il ya procès en
appel ce qu'il me tiendrai encore
pendant longtemps de ce gouvernement
sont déjà bien boudé devant là c'est
plus aucun délai n'étant imposée à la
chambre d'appel de la cpi
les deux hommes vont devoir attendre
plusieurs semaines voire plusieurs mois
avant de connaître leur sort
une situation qui laisse planer le doute
sur la date de leur retour en côte
d'ivoire mais aussi leur participation à
la prochaine présidentielle
et pour en parler nous sommes avec frank
toti journalistes ivoiriens bonsoir
franck petit merci d'être avec nous
alors les juges de la chambre d'appel de
la cour pénale internationale ont entamé
leur délibéré on lisait doivent se
prononcer sur l'appel de fait tout
bensouda oppose l équipement que peut-on
attendre selon vous boussois l'état
tuyaux et une beurrée la cour d'appel en
faveur des et il confirme en
l'acquittement des charges et laurent
gbagbo ne seront donc totalement libre
mille de rentrer en côte d'ivoire libre
des équipes activités politiques
deuxième de cette possibilité on à
l'annulation du nom ce cas d'espèce ou
la coupure en tas est nouveau au cette
nouvelle procédure où elle laisse le
choix à n'importe quelle juridiction est
complet un pommeau d'ivoire partout dans
le monde le pouvoir pour celle du
nouveau monsieur laurent gbagbo et pour
l'avocat de laurent gbagbo la procureur
cherche aussi à rejeter la
responsabilité de son échec sur sur les
jeux
je que pensez vous de cette analyse mme
aussant encore une fois dans du
dilatoire savait déjà la chanson primée
de la série avait déjà renvoyé la ou pis
de madame à madame la procureure ou
approfondi les ec être parce que les
chasses hyperviseurs et humaine
mais les chaînes accusations n'étaient
pas soutenues par des preuves discours
préliminaire
on a eu plusieurs années les procédures
avant la rue mais on arrivait justement
au procès qui a débuté en 2007 où
s'achevait en 2009
la procureure avec auprès de certains de
ces témoins n'a pas eu à prouver que
monsieur laurent gbagbo charles blé
goudé était coupable justement les chefs
d'accusation pour lesquels c'est un peu
chez lui pour la chambre a estimé que
non seulement les payes suffisante mais
ce n'était même pas du tout si on peut
le dise de magasins simply seule
pelleteuse était dans la chambre a
décidé d l'acquittement et d'une remise
en liberté immédiate de dieu coaccusés
malheureusement dans cette histoire il
n'y a pas d'autre mot que puisse
qualifier
merci frank toti journalistes ivoiriens
d'avoir été avec nous nous avoir apporté
votre analyse
dans un peu moins de
mais dans un peu moins d'une semaine
débutera le projet d'annexion d'une
partie de la cisjordanie
mercredi prochain le gouvernement
israélien détaillera sa stratégie un
plan pensé par les états unis et israël
qui suscite de vives inquiétudes aux
yeux des palestiniens et de la
communauté internationale l'onu et la
ligue arabe ont appelé hier l'état
hébreu abandonné le projet et l'a même
aidé j'aide les décisions des israéliens
sur une extension de leur souveraineté
sur ces territoires sont des décisions
qui reviennent aux israéliens je crois
que le premier ministre israélien a fait
sien notre objectif c'est à dire que
notre vision pour la paix au
moyen-orient soit couronnée de succès
par ces mots washington donne de facto
son feu vert à israël pour l'annexion de
pans entiers de la cisjordanie occupée
les états unis veulent voir le plan de
donald trump pour le proche orient se
concrétiser les projets d'annexion
rencontre pourtant une opposition
grandissante à l'onu son secrétaire
général a d'ailleurs demandé ce mercredi
à israël de renoncer à ces plans qui
pourraient mettre fin aux efforts
internationaux en faveur de la création
d'un état palestinien viable
cette annexion si elle était mise en
oeuvre constituerait une violation des
plus graves du droit international
nu et ré sévèrement à la perspective
d'une solution à deux états et
amoindrirait les possibilités d'une
reprise des négociations si les
palestiniens sentent qu'il n'y a pas de
perspective pour une résolution
pacifique du conflit
cela ne fera que créer des opportunités
pour des radicaux des personnes avec des
intentions dévastatrice pour venir
remplir ce vide des mises en garde
lancées sans pour autant parler de
sanction lors d'une visioconférence du
conseil de sécurité de l'onu toute
dernière rencontre internationale avant
la possible mise en oeuvre dès le 1er
juillet de ses plans d'annexion
pour le chef de la diplomatie
palestinienne riyad al malki tout
l'annexion de territoires palestiniens
par israël serait un crime
quant à la diplomatie israélienne avait
réagi par la voix de son ambassadeur à
l'onu devant le conseil
il a reproché aux palestiniens d'avoir
refusé de venir négocier avec son pays
rejetée en bloc par les palestiniens
projet d' administration américaine a
aussi été dénoncée par l'union
européenne et la ligue arabe annexé des
parties du territoires palestiniens
occupés constituerait si cela se
concrétise il menace sérieuse à la
stabilité régionale ce plan détruirait
toute idée de paix à l'avenir dans ce
climat de crainte à la proche du 1er
juillet le mouvement armé palestinien le
hamas a lui haussé le ton la résistance
considère cette décision d'annexion de
la cisjordanie et de la vallée du
jourdain comme une déclaration de guerre
contre notre peuple palestinien la
résistance dans cette guerre sera un
gardien fidèles de ce peuple et de ses
lieux saints
dans le détail ce plan pour le
proche-orient des états unis prévoit
l'annexion par israël de la vallée du
jourdain et de la centaine de colonies
en cisjordanie où sont installés 450
mille israéliens les colonies pourtant
illégales au regard du droit
international
s'ajoute à cela la création d'un état
palestinien sur un territoire réduit est
mort seul et sans jérusalem est pour
capitale
les palestiniens réclament des sanctions
et envisage désormais de saisir la cour
internationale de justice
moi c'est la fin de cette émission merci
d'avoir suivi on se retrouve à 22 heures
pile pour un point complet sur
l'actuelle
[Musique]
non
bt a mis sur la table une série de
mesures pour aider le secteur 18
milliards d'euros pour le tourisme là
pour l'instant via les aides encore les
aides et donc que les choses vont se
compliquer à la rentrée bon ok ça parle
beaucoup mais il faut il faut du concret
et les fonds de solidarité de 1500 euros
et ses terrasses et des pacotilles tout
ça c'est sais c'est mal fait c'est mal
préparée donc comment voulez vous que
les gens s'y retrouvent
le plus dur c'est à venir et c'est là où
on la remonte contrôler ça va être
compliqué de faire revenir les gens pour
la bonne et simple raison qu'on a tous
perdu beaucoup de revenus
donc de toute façon on est heureux on
est dans une impasse
[Musique]
vous parlez de résilience comment est-ce
qu'on pourrait le définir
c'est après un traumatisme qu'est ce
qu'on fait combien on reste traumatisée
mais on cherche en soi et autour de
soins quels sont les facteurs qui vont
permettre de reprendre un nouveau
développement est l'un en 42 résilience
la catastrophe économique dont on parle
elle est liée directement au confinement
c'est à dire à la mise en coma
artificiel de l'économie catastrophe ça
veut dire à côté
cata strophe haye il ya un tournant mais
on recevait à vivre mais dans une autre
direction c'est la première fois dans
l'histoire de l'humanité que pour sauver
des vies humaines en ruines
la moitié de la planète jamais on a fait
ça jamais quel d'une décision
invraisemblable pour vos ça dépend
telles valeurs on attribuait la mort la
vie humaine
si on considère que la vie humaine est
plus précieuse que l'économie on a bien
fait mais si on considère que maintenant
il va y avoir des catastrophes humaines
individuelles avec cette décision
alors je sais pas c'est un débat n'aura
un débat éthique
certains disent que nous ne sommes pas
une chaîne française
d'autres affirment même que nous ne
sommes pas journalistes mais vous
[Musique]
savez-vous vraiment qui nous sommes
les valeurs que nous défendons la
liberté
la liberté d'expression et d'opinion
nous défendons l'égalité l'égalité des
chances pour tous
[Musique]
nous sommes une équipe
nous sommes cette diversité qui fait la
france
et nous en sommes fiers
[Musique]
et si vous veniez voir par vous même
recevons pauline d'orgeval présidente et
cofondatrice de kohat petit santé le
pratiquent même de notre association
c'est de réduire les inégalités d'accès
à la santé et d'accès aux soins
on se rencontre que les personnes en
situation de handicap notamment ont été
largement oubliée et donc je finisse par
renoncer aux soins vous avez proposé
deux posters en falck ça que ça veut
dire
facile à lire facile à comprendre on a
fait des posters sur ce qu'était le
confinement à l'aide d'illustrations et
à l'aide de phrases très simple de
permettre à tous y compris des personnes
avec déficience intellectuelle ou avec
autisme de comprendre ce qui se passe
tout l'enjeu de notre association c'est
construire les fiches avec les acteurs
associatifs institutionnels
voilà tout se met en place pour
accompagner dans la durée
[Musique]
ici on écoute ceux qui ne sont pas
d'accord
[Musique]
ici on invite les plus compétents pas
seulement ceux qui parlent le plus fort
[Musique]
ici on reçoit ce qu'on voit pas ailleurs
parce que si seul interdit d'interdire
[Musique]
l'écologie ce n'est pas de la politique
dernier rapport du giec sur les océans
comme ça faut ça fout les jetons
on est dans une espèce de déni collectif
on ne veut pas croire ce qu'on sait et
scientifique parle quand même de la
sixième extinction de la vie sur terre
sixième extinction et la vie sur terre à
d'autres experts qui contestent leur
usine en russie
personne non non c'est pas vrai il ya
des crimes à tous et maintenant et non
ce n'est pas il y en a pas il ya des
gens qui ne sont pas des chercheurs qui
parlent que la presse met en avant parce
que il faut que du débat il ya plus de
débat aujourd'hui il n'y a plus aucun
débat ce changement climatique et on va
vers une vraie par une catastrophe ou 20
vers une vraie catastrophe et on est
incapable d'en prendre conscience
mais ce n'est pas des pessimistes de
comprendre ce qui va arriver pour moi je
pense qu'on est comme une guerre
aujourd'hui on est entré en guerre
contre nos façons vu et l'ennemi y'en a
pas d'ennemis l'ennemi c'est nous
[Musique]
vous êtes philosophe de formation mais
philosophe aussi de profession est ce
qui explique cette énergie que vous
mettez cet engagement critiques contre
le féminisme actuelle je pense que un
modèle de société est à bout de souffle
et que nous avons en effet besoin de
repenser le fondement anthropologique et
philosophique du monde dans lequel nous
vivons
quels rapports nous devons instaurer aux
êtres et aux choses
on s'oriente le poids d une société très
puritaine oui puritaine au sens où le
désir et et criminaliser le fait que
l'homme soit sensible aux charmes
féminins et rendu suspect
[Musique]
aps la crise du courant d'un virus
s'aggrave en amérique latine la
situation est effectivement assez
cataclysmique
la pandémie est en train de détruire
l'espoir de nombreuses familles à
travers le monde
présidant un brésilien g1 black sun araw
ni la gravité de la pandémie il a été
élu c'est par un dictateur il reste
encore populaire et donc évidemment sa
façon de se comporter par rapport au
virus a de l'impact auprès des
brésiliens aujourd'hui le gouvernement
travaille fortement pour s'approprier
les territoires des peuples indigènes
si amazon y disparaître nous aussi nous
disparaîtrons l'humanité disparaîtra
arrêter un peu cette accélération pour
l'économie et pour le développement
global car nous avons besoin aussi
d'être en paix et en harmonie tout
[Musique]
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose une
convention admise par tous s'il lui
arrive quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins ou
du bon vieux cash
nous vous parlerons de tout sans langue
de bois
[Musique]
bertrand piccard vous vouliez prouvé que
l'on pouvait voyager au solaire et vous
avez fait le tour du monde
moi mon ambition c'est de montrer que
les technologies propres et les énergies
renouvelables peuvent faire des choses a
priori impossible sur la rime paul
c'était vraiment le laboratoire volant
qui montrait que non seulement on
pouvait s'alimenter au solaire non plus
on pouvait être extrêmement efficients
sur le plan de l'énergie par rapport aux
problèmes là du climat de
l'environnement il ya un état d'urgence
actuellement il ya un état d'urgence
on est en train de détruire la
biodiversité s'accélère l'habitation ça
s'accélère de manière exponentielle ça
veut dire que chaque minute l'écart
entre ce qu'on fait est ce qu'on devrait
faire augmenter
oui donc c'est de plus en plus graves
[Musique]
m
certains disent que nous ne sommes pas
une chaîne française
d'autres affirment même que nous ne
sommes pas journalistes mais vous
[Musique]
savez-vous vraiment qui nous sommes
les valeurs que nous défendons
la liberté
la liberté d'expression et d'opinion
nous défendons l'égalité l'égalité des
chances pour tous
[Musique]
nous sommes une équipe
nous sommes cette diversité qui fait la
france
et nous en sommes fiers
[Musique]
et si vous veniez voir par vous même
l'histoire est plus compliquée que
certains veulent nous le faire croire
vouloir la réécrire pour faire oublier
les échecs ne permet pas de comprendre
ce qui s'est vraiment passé
c'est ainsi que dans certains manuels de
cours d'histoire de nos enfants on veut
faire oublier napoléon bonaparte grand
organisateur de l'état moderne au profit
de robespierre
le père de la terre j'ai écouté le
président entrant pratiquer le déni en
oubliant carrément l'allier qui a eu le
triste privilège d'avoir le plus grand
nombre de morts dans la deuxième guerre
mondiale mais si j'ai bien compris ils
sont morts pour rien puisque au nom
d'une idéologie on nie leur existence en
oubliant une partie de la game
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pas de violence pas de police violente
pas de police assiste selon la
sémantique de christophe castaner le
ministre de l'intérieur auditionné cet
après midi par les sénateurs alors que
la militante contre les violences
policières à ça traoré s'apprête à
recevoir un prix dimanche aux états unis
une campagne de tests virologie de
grande ampleur telle est la stratégie
d'olivier véran pour identifier les
foyers de contamination dormant lié aux
porcs à des virus
alors que les auditions de la commission
d' enquête parlementaire au lendemain de
celle du professeur à hoult se
poursuivre
l'élysée charge une mission indépendante
d'évaluer la gestion de la crise un
premier rapport est attendu à l'automne
donald trump annoncé il y à peu retiré
ses soldats d'allemagne le locataire de
la maison blanche affirmé hier qu'il
comptait diriger une partie de ce
contingent à vers la pologne
une annonce faite alors que le président
polonais
briguera un deuxième mandat dans
quelques jours était précisément à
washington
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue sur rt france
si vous nous rejoignez christophe
castaner face aux sénateurs cet après
midi le ministre de l'intérieur a été
auditionné par la mission d'information
du palais du luxembourg sur les méthodes
d'action et d'intervention des forces de
l'ordre
en cause notamment les violences
policières et la technique controversée
dite de l'étranglement et précision à
devant le sénat de notre reporter lit la
femme publique
c'est un véritable numéro d'équilibriste
auquel s'est livré le ministre de
l'intérieur pendant plusieurs heures
devant la commission sénatoriale
christophe castaner qui d'un côté a
tenté d'apporter des réponses aux
problèmes des violences policières tout
en essayant de ménager les syndicats
christophe castaner d'ailleurs a tenu à
rappeler l'action gouvernementale en
matière de sécurité il s'est montré
particulièrement positive dans le bilan
qu'il a dressée il a tenu à rappeler que
depuis 2010 est la priorité accordée à
la sécurité s'était traduite par une
hausse du budget de plus d'un milliard
d'euros christophe castaner qui se
savait attendu sur ce point et qui a
tenu à le rappeler si certains pouvaient
en douter qu'il est définitivement du
côté des forces de l'ordre à écouter
nous devons le défendre sans cesse face
aux amalgames et aux accusations qu'ils
subissent les défendre face aux insultes
face aux coûts les défendre face à cette
accusation siens juste de racisme ou de
violence structurelle organisée je les
10000 fois je le dis une fois de plus il
n'y a pas de police violente
il n'y a pas de police racistes avec
laurent nunez
nous nous y employons depuis 20 mois et
nous ne cesserons de le faire et de le
dire nous avons confiance dans nos
forces de l'ordre nous ne cesserons
jamais de les soutenir leur accorder les
moyens dont ils ont besoin pour
accomplir leur devoir et je vous le dis
nous sommes fiers de nos policiers fiers
de nos gendarmes comme eux mêmes doivent
être fiers du métier qu'ils font au
service des français au service de la
république
policiers et gendarmes sont les forces
de l'ordre au fond ils sont les forces
de la république que nous ne devons pas
l'oublier
concernant les méthodes d'intervention
qui sont a très fortement contesté ces
dernières semaines notamment celle dite
de la clé d'étranglement qui est
d'ailleurs
mise en cause dans la mort de cédric
shui art en janvier dernier à paris le
ministre de l'intérieur a annoncé que
cette méthode ne serait plus enseignée
dans les écoles de police il a
d'ailleurs évoqué la mise en place ans
de réflexion qui sont en cours pour
trouver à des méthodes alternatives je
propose l'écouté
j'ai demandé à ce que soit lancé un
groupe de travail conjoint entre la
police et la gendarmerie pour passer en
revue les techniques d'interpellation
à l'issue de ces travaux et estimant la
méthode comme dangereuse le directeur
général de la police nationale m'a
proposé de surseoir à l'enseignement de
l'étranglement
d'ailleurs elle n'est plus enseignée
depuis le début des années 2000 dans la
gendarmerie nationale ni dans
l'administration pénitentiaire et donc
en conséquence avec laurent nunez nous
avons décidé de mettre fin à son
enseignement
nous avons également et il n'y a pas eu
d'évolution ni de rétropédalage demander
un nouveau groupe de travail de faire
des propositions très vite d'ici le 1er
septembre pour trouver des alternatives
à cette méthode
je suis convaincu aussi que nous devons
faire monter en puissance la formation
continue des policiers et gendarmes sur
la voie publique et c'est pourquoi j'ai
décidé que les policiers et gendarmes
devraient désormais suivre un nombre
d'heures annuel minimal de formation aux
techniques d'intervention sans quoi il
ne pourrait plus exercer sur la voie
publique
c'est un ministre très fragilisée qui
s'est présenté aujourd'hui devant la
commission sénatoriale à la fois très
critiquée par ses troupes mais aussi
politiquement très fragilisé il se
murmure même qu'il pourrait perdre son
poste au ministère de l'intérieur
après les élections municipales en cas
de remaniement christophe castaner qui
est la première personnalité à se
présenter devant cette mission qui a été
mise en place le 16 juin dernier
devraient suivre les inspection générale
de la police nationale mais aussi
de la gendarmerie nationale ainsi que
des représentants syndicaux qui devrait
entendues d'ici la fin du mois de
juillet et pour jean pierre colombiès
porte parole de l'association de police
union des policiers nationaux
indépendants les déboires que
connaissent les forces de l'ordre
aujourd'hui sont également imputable aux
politiques passées à l'évidence ne
compte n'y est pas il ne peut pas y être
tout simplement parce que ça part comme
il le dit là pour le coup il faut lui
rendre cette justice sa part de très
loin des gouvernements qui ont précédé
celui ci n'ont pas pris en compte le
malaise et les difficultés profondes qui
règne au sein de cette institution
gouvernements précédents d'ailleurs je
voudrais traduit que quelqu'un lui
rappelle un certain que emmanuel macron
faisait partie je rappelle qu'il était
quand même secrétaire générale sous la
présidence hollande est également
ministre du budget et comme l'a rappelé
monsieur castaner c'est tout part
souvent justement des arbitrages qui
sont effectués à bercy donc rendons à
césar ce qui est à césar et si
aujourd'hui on ne peut constater que tu
dirais globalement des échecs multiples
à tous les niveaux au niveau du maintien
de l'ordre au niveau de l'implantation
dans les secteurs au niveau des
méthodologies et bien c'est un petit peu
parce que des hommes au pouvoir
aujourd'hui n'ont pas tiré les
conséquences si de leçons du pouvoir
passé et alors que les manifestations se
multipliaient depuis le déconfinement le
ministre de la santé appelle à éviter
les grands rassemblements et les
comportements à risques annonce
aujourd'hui d'olivier et veyran dans un
entretien au monde il évoque une
campagne de tests virologiques de grande
ampleur pour identifier les éventuels
cluster dormant concerner 3 millions
d'habitants dans 30 communes elles d'île
de france notamment et une
expérimentation sur la base du
volontariat qui pourra ensuite être
étendu à d'autres régions
olivier verront leur appel a proposé
hier 6 milliards d'euros pour les
hausses de salaires des soignants à
partir du 1er juillet annonce accueillie
tièdement par les syndicats un mois
après le lancement du ségur de la santé
et sur la gestion des crises du corona
virus en france vous propose justement
d'écouter les analyses de bertrand
legrand aux médecins généralistes et
catherine hill épidémiologiste
c'est évident que les essais de des
traitements ont été catastrophiques en
france qu'en fond on n'a pas beaucoup de
résultats à mettre sur la table
on peut comparer à ce qu'ont fait les
anglais ils ont fait un grand essai dans
lequel ils ont testé plusieurs
traitements et ils nous ont apporté
plusieurs résultats que la dexaméthasone
est utile et que l'hydroxyde coquine à
l'hôpital n'est pas vraiment utile
donc voilà il va falloir effectivement
faire le bilan de ça et penser à
réorganiser la façon de faire les études
de médicaments et le professeur raout a
démontré une compétence absolue dans
l'évaluation des médicaments à pékin
après avoir eu zéro cas pendant quatre
semaines
tout d'un coup il ya eu de nouveaux 30
cas par jour et on a fait très attention
re confiné tester s'est désinfecté et
c'est ici on a ça sent capable on a tout
le monde s'en fiche complètement
donc l'épidémie n'est pas finie la
première vague n'est pas fini le virus
est là je fais pas partie de ceux qui
jettent la pierre aux laboratoires ou
inversement qui sont des aficionados des
de la pureté absolue
je pense que les laboratoires ont tout
intérêt à ce que la science avance et
donc du coup par définition ils
s'adressent à des spécialistes et ses
histoires de il faut absolument inclure
ne plus avoir aucun lien avec les
laboratoires nous ont conduit à
supprimer toutes les capacités de
formation de nos internes et qui
aujourd'hui peine bien à avoir les
subsides de l'état pour obtenir le
financement de leur formation donc
l'état veut supprimer les subsides des
laboratoires sait très bien qu'ils
payent à sa place et là on se sera
parfait on s'est contenté d'un débat
politique pro ou anti raul complètement
stérile qui sert à rien et voilà on a
deux camps d'ayatollahs qui s'affrontent
les uns les autres et qui ne veut ou ne
produisent ni dans un sens ni dans un
autre et on en vient cette manifestation
aujourd'hui celle des syndicats et
ex-salarié de
lux faire devant le site de gerzat près
de clermont ferrand
un rassemblement avec un double objectif
obtenir la relocalisation de l'usiné
dire non au déclin industriel de la
région avant sa fermeture fin novembre
2018 luxfer était la seule usine en
europe à fabriquer des bouteilles
d'oxygène à vocation médicale 136
salariés ont été licenciés parmi les
manifestants et politique jean-luc
mélenchon et raphaël glucksmann ou
encore le secrétaire général de la cgt
philippe martinez dont on travaille sur
le monde d'après le monde d'après c'est
de réindustrialiser notre pays et aussi
avec un maillage territorial et je pense
qu'il ya besoin dans ce département
comme dans d'autres de non seulement
préserver l'industrie mais de la
développer l'udc ce faire il ya des
salariés très compétent et du
savoir-faire qui ont sûrement manqué
dans la période que nous venons vont
venir que nous venons de vivre puisque
il travaille pour du médical et donc
aujourd'hui la question qui est posée
c'est quand est ce qu quand est ce de
cette entreprise va réouvrir et il faut
que l'état se bouge
c'est ce que j'ai dit à monsieur le
maire que j'ai croisés mardi dernier et
à monsieur macron il faut que l'état
intervienne maintenant directement soit
à travers un repreneur soit en
nationalisant cette entreprise pour que
les emplois soient retrouvées sur ce
site
et pour jean louis borie avocats de
salariés de luxe faire l'état français
doit forcément compris technique à
vendre son régime nous avons plusieurs
repreneurs sous la main plusieurs
industriels se sont largement intéressé
au sujet
les business quand son prêt lusine peut
redémarrer très vite très vite très vite
le seule chose à la seule chose à faire
c'est d'obliger les le groupe
britannique a lâché le site
donc on ne comprend pas pourquoi cela
n'a pas été fait depuis de nombreux mois
pour nous il est évident que ce site est
stratégique stratégique ne serait ce que
pour la france en terme et même pour
l'europe en termes d'autonomie
s'agissant des fabrication de bouteilles
de gaz d'oxygène
plus précisément et puis c'est aussi
capital est important pour la région
parce que vous avez des métallos et un
savoir faire spécifique qui sont très
compétents qui sont capables de faire
redémarrer l'usiné sans délai et en plus
pour la région c'est capital parce
qu'effectivement des suppressions
d'emplois on en voit arriver à l'appel
tout autour de clermont ferrand donc que
l'ultimatum
c'est dire faites en sorte d'utiliser
les moyens juridiques dont vous disposez
pour tordre le bras aux anglais pour que
tout simplement ils acceptent de deux
ans de l'usiné
c'est pas compliqué j moins 3 avant le
second tour des municipales les
candidats ont mené campagne dans un
contexte particulier de crise sanitaire
une campagne à distance pour éviter les
rassemblements avec un principal enjeu
convaincre les français d'aller voter
toute participation au scrutin de
dimanche est la grande inconnue
de son côté julie garnier porte parole
de la france 1 sont mises défend le côté
citoyen de son parti vous savez nous on
s'est appuyé sur des collectifs citoyens
qui ont défendu qui défendent des
mesures très concrètes à savoir
l'encadrement des loyers la cantine
gratuite réguler le prix de l'eau
création d hébergement d'urgence fixe
etc
on est présent dans pratiquement toutes
les grandes villes et les villes
galement de taille plus modeste à savoir
paris lyon marseille toulouse clairement
je vais pas toutes les citer parce que
je vais en oublier et on me prendre à
nous ce que nous voulons c'est que quand
il faudra dénoncer des pratiques
on pourra le faire on n'aura pas besoin
de rendre des comptes à des lobbys ou à
des entreprises du cac 40 ce n'est pas
grâce à eux que nous serons élus ce sera
grâce à la voix des gens du peuple et
c'est ça qui compte le premier on a
besoin de personnes qui comprennent que
la vie des gens ses doigts c'est ce qui
doit passer en premier
et pour ça on a besoin de tout le monde
en a besoin des citoyens et c'est pour
ça que la france soumise est un
mouvement qui respire de ça c'est à dire
qu'ils respirent de ces collectifs de
ces groupes d'appui qui existe partout
on a besoin de tout le monde et c'est
pour ça qu'on a voulu inclure tout le
monde un départ précipité pour bruxelles
qui interroge dans le viseur de la
presse outre-rhin la présidente de la
commission européenne ursula von der
leyen en poste depuis bientôt un an
l'ancien ministre la défense allemande
est vivement critiquée aujourd'hui dans
un rapport rédigé par les députés issus
de l'opposition
sa gestion du ministère de 2013 à 2019
est décrite comme un échec complet avec
des dizaines de millions d'euros mal
dépensé pour des consultants conseiller
ou encore entre autres sous traitants
privés une commission d enquête
parlementaire arrêté depuis ouverte qui
ces conclusions définitives devraient
être rendues la semaine prochaine
ursula von der leyen bénéficierait d'un
soutien non négligeable celui d'angela
merkel selon françois poulet mathis j'en
ai les spécialistes europe voire des
cabinets privés qui s'empare d'une
certaine manière de consulter de
consulteur de poste de consultant pour
des questions ou intimement stratégique
c'est quand même inquiétant pour un
ministère de la défense qui je le
rappelle est quand même
il s'est régalé en allemagne donc on
peut estimer effectivement que cette
affaire n'est pas terminée
cela dit je pense que la semaine
prochaine lorsqu'on aura les résultats
de l enquête conjointe
opposition et majorité peut-être que les
choses vont se clarifier un petit peu
dans la mesure où angela merkel est bien
décidé à défendre coûte que coûte sa
candidate qui a reçu l'aval des
relayeurs c'est possible mais il faudra
prouver c'est toujours le problème des
preuves photos et quelles preuves
est ce que véritablement elle n'était
pas au courant et ça c'est une véritable
enquête judiciaire qui doit être mené en
allemagne
cela dit c'est vrai que étant à
bruxelles elle est relativement protégé
donc elle a un poste qui la protège
c'est un petit peu d'ailleurs ce qu'on
lui avait reproché c'est d'aller à
bruxelles sous forme de fuite en quelque
sorte un dessin des américains seront
prochainement envoyés en pologne c'est
l'annoncé faite par le président
américain hier alors que les relations
entre donald trump et en gala merkel
sont tendus washington se rapproche donc
désormais de la pologne france pratiqué
vite partir d'allemagne pour la pologne
c'est l'annnonce de donald trump alors
qu'il recevait à la maison blanche son
homologue polonais andrezj duda nous
allons réunir nos forces en allemagne
certains rentreront à la maison d'autres
iront ailleurs mais la pologne sera l'un
de ses autres endroits ces autres
endroits en europe
aucun détail sur les chiffre n'a été
donné mais cette annonce intervient dans
un contexte de tension entre les états
unis l'allemagne il ya quelques jours le
président américain avait évoqué la
diminution des troupes américaines
basées en allemagne de 52000 à 25 mille
hommes reprochant notamment à berlin des
impayés dans sa contribution à l'otan
l'allemagne sont des délinquants ce sont
des délinquants depuis des années ça
fait des années qu'ils ont des arriérés
et ils doivent des milliards de dollars
à l'otan il faut qu'il paie une présence
américaine en allemagne importante pour
la sécurité américaine et européenne
avait déclaré en réponse le lendemain le
ministre allemand des affaires
étrangères
ce mercredi depuis les jardins de la
maison blanche le président polonais a
assuré qu'il n'avait pas demandé à
donald trump de transférer les troubles
dans son pays mais avoue lui avoir
demandé de ne pas retirer de soldats
américains
europe mais georges samedi chercheur au
global policiers in situ dont nous
explique pourquoi le président américain
se tourner vers la pologne pour
accueillir les soldats américains
la pologne est un ami fiable pour donald
trump
oui donald trump en a pas beaucoup en
europe 1 ce moment notamment l'allemagne
n'est pas vraiment une grande amie donc
ils aiment guidée de glorifier la
pologne qui correspond qui remplit ses
obligations par exemple en matière de
portions du bébé consacrées aux dépenses
militaires contrairement à l'allemagne
contrairement à l'allemagne la pologne
achète du gaz naturel liquéfié aux états
unis alors que l'allemagne achète son
gaz naturel à la russie a grâce au
gazoduc nord stream 2 et bien sûr cela
irrite fortement donald trump
il ya également peut-être un peu de
sympathie politique envers le
gouvernement conservateur du président
tout au lendemain des commémorations de
la victoire sur l'allemagne nazie place
au référendum constitutionnel en russie
est la consultation a commencé
aujourd'hui et durera jusqu'au 1er
juillet scrutin étalé sur la longueur
pour éviter une trop forte affluence
pandémies comme les virus oblige les
russes se prononce pour entériner oui ou
non un ensemble de réformes de la
constitution a remis les mesures la
possibilité pour vladimir poutine
d'effectuer deux mandats présidentiels
supplémentaires à partir de 2024
d'abitex en janvier dernier le président
russe surprend tout le monde en
proposant d'apporter des amendements à
la constitution
quelques heures après cette annonce le
gouvernement décide de démissionner la
constitution actuelle date de 1993 et a
été mise en place sous boris elstine
élaboré sur les décombres de l'ère
soviétique
elle est l'objet de critiques dues à
l'hyper présidentialisation du jeu
politique qu'elle induit c'est aussi une
constitution qui n'est dans le sang
à l'époque le parlement contrôlé par les
communistes hostiles au projet tente de
destituer helsinn pour rester au pouvoir
il fait appel à l'armée 187 personnes
sont tuées durant cet automne l'un des
objectifs principaux de ce changement de
constitution et donc de mettre fin à ce
système tout en conservant intactes les
bases de la constitution à l'heure
actuelle seul le président peut nommer
le chef du gouvernement et les ministres
le parlement donne juste son feu vert
formel le changement proposé renforcera
le pouvoir du parlement qui aura le
dernier mot concernant la composition du
gouvernement tandis que le président ne
sera pas en mesure de s'y opposer les
pouvoirs seront ainsi redistribués entre
les différentes branches afin
d'équilibrer le système de gouvernance
russe un autre changement important
porte sur la limitation des mandats
présidentiels à deux au total au lieu de
deux mandats consécutifs actuellement
cela implique que les futurs chefs
d'état ne pourront pas rester au pouvoir
aussi longtemps que vladimir poutine
un changement qui obnubile les médias
occidentaux selon les règles existantes
à vladimir poutine
elle doit partir dans quatre ans à la
fin de son second mandat consécutif
son quatrième au total les membres du
parlement ont néanmoins proposé de
remettre à zéro le compteur de ses
mandats avec des amendements je propose
soit de lever la limitation du nombre de
mandats présidentiels soin d'inclure
dans un article du projet de loi une
clause permettant au président actuel
une fois que la constitution modifiée
sera entrée en vigueur de se porter
candidat à l'élection présidentielle
comme à tout autre citoyen
cela signifie que poutine pourra se
porter candidat en 2024 et en 2030 s'ils
le souhaitent
pour vladimir poutine ces changements
dans la constitution vise à mettre en
place un état providence nash notre
tâche commune la plus importante est de
faire en sorte que les résultats du
référendum soit absolument incontestable
et légitime légitime
mini et 4e n'a mis que vous savez
j'avais déjà parlé à plusieurs reprises
dans l'ensemble ces amendements à la
constitution n'exigeait pas il n'existe
pas selon la loi en vigueur
l'organisation d'un référendum mais j'ai
estimé qu'il était très important pour
que les gens expriment directement leurs
opinions sur les amendements proposés
soyaux prix moyen d'achat n'y que tu
aimes pas peur comme catherine ringer
il y à plus de 140 amendements l'un de
garantie que le salaire minimum ne peut
pas être inférieur au coût de la vie un
autre changement consacre la primauté du
droit russe sur le droit international
certaines propositions font l'objet de
débats par exemple le mariage sera
uniquement considérée comme l'union
entre un homme et une femme dieu sera
également mentionné même si la russie
restera un état laïque est des
propositions qui sont soumises à un
référendum
les modifications seront donc adopter
uniquement si les citoyens russes les
approuvent
trois jours d'audition qui se sont
achevés hier à la haye aux pays-bas
laurent gbagbo ex président de la côte
d'ivoire et son ministre charles blé
goudé ont comparu devant la cour pénale
internationale pour crimes contre
l'humanité juges avocats et greffiers
ont entamé leur délibéré qui ne devrait
pas être rendu avant longtemps chéri
elle benavides bulot comme un sentiment
de fermeté en ce début de semaine à la
cour pénale internationale de la haye
cette impression là seule la doit à la
procureur fatou bensouda qui a demandé
un procès en appel à la suite d
acquittement de laurent gbagbo et
charles blé goudé en janvier 2019
les deux ex dirigeants ivoiriens sont
accusés d'avoir perpétré des massacres
en 2010 et 2011
lors des violences post électorales qui
avaient coûté la vie à trois mille
personnes
les deux hommes avaient été reconnus non
coupables de crimes contre l'humanité
par erreur la chambre de première
instance a commis une erreur en
acquittant monsieur gbagbo et monsieur
blé goudé en violation de ses
obligations fondamentales au titre de
l'article 74 5 vs
c'est fait et d'autres faits objectifs
vont tous dans le même sens
la majorité n'a pas achevé les
artiste de raisonnement complet requis
par l'article 74
au moment où elle a été acquittée
oralement en janvier 2019
des auditions partiellement virtuel en
raison de la crise sanitaire lié aux
coronavirus les juges ont entamé un
délibéré pour savoir si un procès en
appel doit bien avoir lieu
le seul moyen selon les victimes de ces
crises ivoiriennes que justice soit
rendue mais rien n'est joué même si
possible souhaité balaie pas besoin de
visa laurent gbagbo c'est qu'il n'ya pas
de suite favorable à la demande formulée
par mme bensouda est donc quelques la
lonab à bollène michel boudet soient
acquittés qui puisse regagner la côte
d'ivoire d'un autre côté il ya la
possibilité au style que la cour estime
que la demande formulée par madame des
rivales et donc il ya un procès en appel
ce qui mènerait à bord pendant longtemps
monsieur laurent gbagbo n'est jamais au
bout de vos lacets plus aucun délai
n'étant imposée à la chambre d'appel de
la cpi
les deux hommes vont devoir attendre
plusieurs semaines voire plusieurs mois
avant de connaître leur sort
une situation qui laisse planer le doute
sur la date de leur retour en côte
d'ivoire mais aussi leur participation à
la prochaine présidentielle - tension
toujours vive en rdc la police est à
nouveau intervenu hier pour disperser
des manifestants qui s'étaient
rassemblés autour du parlement à
kinshasa protestation pour le deuxième
jour consécutif en trois propositions de
loi concernant le fonctionnement de la
justice elle porte sur le ski les
magistrats et l'organisation le
fonctionnement et les compétences des
juridictions de l'ordre judiciaire la
coalition au pouvoir depuis janvier 2019
n'est pas sur la même ligne
rappelons que cette coalition est issue
d'un accord entre le président de la
république
l'ex opposant felix 6 et y élit les
forces de son prédécesseur joseph kabila
majoritaire au parlement
alors quelle sortie crise le point de
vue d'alfred inchangé au maître de
conférences à la sorbonne
la seule issue possible c'est le retrait
de ces trois propositions de loi mais je
crois qu'il ya des manoeuvres en
coulisses qui sont qui se tiennent pour
effectivement amené à aubin minaku à
retirer la proposition de loi parce
qu'on l'a vu même au sein de l'assemblée
dans la commission politique
administrative et justice sakata l'inde
et à ceux qui ont proposé un avec minaku
ces trois projets des propositions de
loi être très embarrassé devant les
députés devant les juristes des gens les
constitutionnalistes il n'a pas su
expliquer le pourquoi
l'opportunité au fond de cette c3
propositions là donc il ya que le
retrait qui va calmer l'opinion mais je
crois que la rupture entre les durs ne
partenaires et consommer que certains
même au sein de ce2 de cette coalition
du pprd donc le fcc demande même qu'on
rompe qu'on sorte de la coalition pour
aller vers la cohabitation et c'est la
fin de cette émission merci de l'avoir
suivi prochain rendez-vous avec
l'actualité demain 7h du matin heure
française excellente soirée à tous
[Musique]
on
le fait que nous avons eu ce problème de
la pandémie qui a été mondiale va amener
d'autres façons de faire des affaires et
les choses vont beaucoup se concentrer
sur l'humain et sur l'environnement
partout en afrique les présidents
prennent conscience qu'il faut vraiment
se réindustrialiser et là je pense que
l'aco vie va permettre à cette ré
industrialisation cela ne veut pas dire
qu'on ne doit plus commercer mais
remercié de manière différents qui
permettent à tout un chacun d'avoir un
travail décent un salaire décent
je pense que le salaire qui permet de
vivre ça c'est le plus important
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
certains disent que nous ne sommes pas
une chaîne française
d'autres affirment même que nous ne
sommes pas journalistes mais vous
[Musique]
savez-vous vraiment qui nous sommes
les valeurs que nous défendons la
liberté
la liberté d'expression et d'opinion
nous défendons l'égalité l'égalité des
chances pour tous
[Musique]
nous sommes une équipe
nous sommes cette diversité qui fait la
france
et nous en sommes fiers
[Musique]
et si vous veniez voir par vous même
la france la société afghane ne permet
pas aux femmes d'être libres comme les
hommes les hommes peuvent faire ce
qu'ils veulent mais pas les